ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. OUR K. HIGH. BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
APRIL GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GONZALEZ
GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY
LEE LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUICK SILVA
ROMMEL'S REYES THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS. YES RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO CIR TO SMITH STONE
KING CALAVERAS OODUA VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YASIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
HOME GUARD. WE STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY IN HOPES OF YOUR MERCY.
BUT YOU BLESS US IN TODAY
SESSION. GUIDE OUR HEARTS
TOWARDS THE TRUTH. AND GIVE US
THE COURAGE TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS WE CAN FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. I MEAN. THANK
YOU MOM YES SIR. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE MAJORITY LEADER
RANTS WOULD YOU MIND LEADING US
IN THE PLEDGE. REDDING BEGAN I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES. ANDREA.
ISRAEL. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL SOME HUMOR SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY APRIL SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIS LIMITED SEVEN
AM ON A CRISTINA ARCIA SUMMER
FORGET THIS PRESIDING SHIFTPIXY
PARKER AT THE DESK READING
CLERK DAVID ABLEMAN READING THE
FOLLOWING ARE PLACED UPON THE
MONNING LOCAL SEVENTY FIVE
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BACKING
AND BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI.
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA REYES MOVES.
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS. THAT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION DEPUTATIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES. WE ARE MOVING
TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MEMBERS
WE ARE PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MS
RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY THREE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE TO
TAKE UP AB AT BURKE WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. WELL I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX TO WITHDRAW AB NINETY TWO
SENATE BUDGET A FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ORDERED THE BILL
TO SECOND READING.
YOU CAN.
THANKS LEVINE. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY MISTER SPEAKER I WE ARE
SPEAKING ABOUT S. B. NINETY
TWO. THERE WAS REST MR FLOOR
FOR PURPOSE OR THE U. S. IS
BIGGER WE WITHHOLDING EVIDENCE
IN ASTRAL CALL VOTE MET MR
FLOOR IS WITHHOLDING HIS RACE
MOVES A SECOND FIVE MINUTES
BOERNER HORVATH. ON THE ROLE
SUSPENSION MEMBERS AS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE THIS RACE IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. YEAH MISTER
FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
THIS IS PROCEDURAL. THIS RACE
IS ASKING FOR AN HIGH. ON THE
MOTION TO WITHDRAW MISTER
FLORES ASKING FOR A NAIL. THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE. THE CLERK.
WELL CLOSER ALL EYES FIFTY
KNOWS SIXTEEN. MOTION CARRIES A
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. AND PLEASE
RAISE YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE.
MISTER SPEAKER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER THE FOLLOWING BILL TO
COMMITTEE AB TEN FORTY ONE
WEEKS FROM THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB ELEVEN
OH ONE IRWIN FOR THEIR HEARING
ON MAY FOURTH PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE AN ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB
TEN SIXTY FIVE MAIENSCHEIN FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. MEMBERS WE HAVE
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY MEMBERS WE COULD
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION. PLEASE
GIVE ATTENTION TO MAJORITY
LEADER RAY S. MS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THE WATER
BILL. ANY GOOD TENNIS OR AS I
CALL HIM ANYMORE. AND
CONGRATULATE HIM ON HIS
RETIREMENT. MANY OF YOU KNOW
EDDIE AS HE IS A PART OF OUR
WAREHOUSE TEAM AND DURING HIS
TIME WITH THE ASSEMBLY HE
ASSISTED MEMBERS AND OFFICES
WITH THE ESSENTIALS THEY
NEEDED. TO WORK COMFORTABLY.
ALONG THE WAY HE IS BILL TO
MANY FRIENDS AND WILL BE MISSED.
RETIREMENT LIFE FOR ANY WILL
CONSIST OF HIM GOING BACK TO
THE BEAUTIFUL HELLO STILL THE
PLAN HAVE YOU SCHOOL MAY HE GO.
MY OWN FAMILY'S HOMETOWN PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING EDDIE
ON HIS RETIREMENT.
MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THIS
IS A DETERMINING APPRECIATED-
AND HE'S IN MY OFFICE QUITE A
BIT I WANT TO CONGRATULATE HIM
AS RETIREMENT NEXT TO ME AS A
SON CARLOS WHO ACTUALLY WORKS
FOR ME CARLSON THE FIELD REP
FOR L. GROW OFFICE ON WHETHER
THE PRIMO CAN TRADITION
CONTINUES IN THE ASSEMBLY.
CONGRATULATIONS ATTY.
YEAH
MEMBERS MAY HAVE ATTENTION
UNDERSTAND THAT TODAY IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC LEVINE IS
BIRTHDAY MR LEVINE HAPPY
BIRTHDAY SIR. WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
OF THEM IS FIVE TWENTY FIVE AN
IMMENSE FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE WITH
MINUTES FORTY SIX FOR THE
MOENTS TEN FIFTY FIVE AM EMITS
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN MINUTES FIFTEEN
THIRTY ONE MINUTES THREE SIX
NOW WITH THE MEN'S AND ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS. ALL
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. THIS IS A. B. EIGHTY. AND
THE CARBURETOR ASSEMBLY DEVICE
MEMBER BURKE AND ACTOR THAN
TAXATION ACCORDING SIERRA TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MS
BURKE EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
AFRICAN THE SENATE MOMENTS TO
EIGHTY EIGHTY WHICH WILL
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT AND
IMMEDIATE TAX RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
DEVASTATED BY THE CORONA VIRUS
PANDEMIC I WANNA THINK MY
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE FOR THEIR CONSISTENT. AND
PERSISTENT ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE WHICH AFFECTS ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AB AT WILL ENSURE
THAT NO BUSINESS PAYS ON FOR
GIVEN PARTS PAVE TECH
PROTECTION PROGRAM PPP LAWS AND
ALLOWS THAT SUFFERED THOSE THAT
SUFFERED AT LEAST FIVE FOR
REDUCTION IN REVENUE. TO DEDUCT
EXPENSES FOR GIVEN LOANS AND
THEY PUBLIC TRADE COMPANIES
THIS BILL IS THE RESULT OF MORE
MONTHS OF HARD WORK AND A LOT
OF PATIENCE WHILE WE WAITED FOR
GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON HOW TO GIVE
BUSINESSES THIS MUCH NEEDED TAX
RELIEF WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF FEDERAL
FUNDS. WITH SEVENTY SIX COOPER
FROM THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE I
THINK THIS BILL SHOWS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF BUSINESS TO OUR
STATE AND OUR STRONG DESIRE TO
BE GOOD PARTNERS NOT JUST FOR
JOB CREATORS BUT FOR EACH AND
EVERY CALIFORNIA THEY EMPLOY.
BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MS. MR FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK IT WAS A- I. TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB A- THE PAYCHECK
FOR. PROGRAM AND ECONOMIC DOES
LOAN PRO. WERE INSTITUTED TO
HELP BUSINESSES OPEN DURING THE
COVER NINETEEN PAN. BUT WITHOUT.
TO FEDERAL LAW RECEIVE. WOULD
HAVE TO PAY TAXES ON BUSINESS
EXPENSES MADE WITH THE WANTED
FUNDS. AS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
URGENT NEED FOR TAX RELIEF TO
BUSINESSES. THAT I'VE FOUGHT
AGAINST MOUNTING ODDS TO KEEP
THEIR DOORS OPEN. AND EMPLOYEES
ON THEIR PAYROLL. THIS IS A
GREAT AND NECESSARY STEP
TOWARDS OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. AND THE REVISIONS
THIS BILL HAS SEEN A PROFOUND
ISSUE ARE A PROFOUND ASSURANCE.
TO OUR COMMUNITIES THAT WE
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE TAX RELIEF
AYE URGENT. AYE VOTE ON AB
EIGHTY. THANK YOU MR FONG.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MS
BURKE YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. LOCAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS. IT IS OUR TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. CLICK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIED UP. HIGHS
SEVENTY THREE KNOWS ZERO.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. ON ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE ITEMS ELEVEN AND TWELVE
PASS AND RETAIN THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN. AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT FIVE MS POWER QUE
HAN CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SEVEN EIGHT BY SOME
AMERICAN OTHERS AND ACCORDING
TO GOVERNMENT. MS BAQUET HAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH CHANGES ALL
REFERENCES TO OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS FROM HE
AND OR HERE C. TWO GENDER
NEUTRAL LANGUAGE THROUGHOUT OUR
GOVERNMENT CODE FIRST DRAFTED
IN NINETEEN FORTY FIVE THE
GOVERNOR AS WELL AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND EVEN
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE
FREQUENTLY REFERRED TO AS HE-
AS ME MY MANY FEMALE COLLEAGUES
AND OUR FEMALE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS CAN TELL YOU. THIS
LANGUAGE DOES NOT REFLECT
TODAY'S CALIFORNIA WORDS MATTER
REPRESENTATION IS CRUCIAL WOMEN
TRANS PEOPLE AND NON BINARY
INDIVIDUALS ARE COMPLETELY CUT
OUT OF OUR CODE IS A WAVE OF
INCLUSIVITY IN WORD AND DEED
THAT WE MUST CODIFY IS SHORT
THESE REVISIONS TO GOVERNMENT
CODE PUBLICLY DEMONSTRATE THAT
ANYONE CAN BE A LEADER IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL IS
COSPONSORED BY LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR ANIL ANY KINDA LAKIS
AND SUPPORTED BY TREASURE MOCK
CONTROLLER YEE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER LARA AS WELL AS
THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
YOUR AYE THAT. THANK YOU MISTER.
SEEING NO DISCRETIONARY ON THE.
CARCLUB RURAL. THAT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF ARE VOTE. ALL OF.
THE TO VOTE. OKAY. CLARK WELL.
THE CULTURAL TIED UP I SAID
KNOWS. THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
THAT FOR THROUGH TWENTY TWO
OVER. THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY.
AB EIGHT FORTY NINE. KERKORIAN
SO FOURTEEN AMHERST MERRY S. AN
ACRONYM HELP US MS RACE YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS
FOR TO YOU A EIGHT FORTY NINE.
A BILL THAT WOULD PROTECT THE
OF SENIORS LIVING AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE MAXIMUM A
VICTIM CAN RECOVER DAMAGES FROM
VIOLATIONS IS FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
VIOLATIONS OF RESIDENTS
SUFFERED. THIS IS ON CHEST AND
HAS RESULTED IN THE INHUMANE
TREATMENT OF OUR SENIORS. AB
EIGHT FORTY NINE SAFEGUARDS THE
RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS BY
CLARIFYING THAT UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN DAMAGES CAN
BE AWARDED HER VIOLATION OF
RIGHTS RATHER THAN IN TOTAL. IN
THIS WAY WE CAN BALANCE THE
SCALES OF JUSTICE AND ENSURE
THAT THOSE. WHO HARM OUR
SENIORS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AND THAT SUCH ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL SERVE AS A DETERRENT TO
OTHERS. AS YOU WORK ON THIS
BILL I DO PLAN TO CONTINUE TO
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO RESOLVE THEIR
CONCERNS TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU MISS REYES.
SENIOR DISCUSSION I'M SORRY MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I AM THE
VICE CHAIR OF LONG TERM CARE
NAY JEAN. AND WITH THE CHAIR
HAVE OBSERVED. NURSING HOME
PROBLEMS ESPECIALLY DURING COLD
FOOD WE WENT FROM FOUR HUNDRED
INSPECTORS ARE SO TO DOWN TO
SIXTY SEVEN INSPECTORS GOING
INTO THE NURSING HOMES WE HAVE
NO IDEA IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT THESE NURSING
HOMES ARE DOING THE INMATES.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE WORD THAT
IS IN MY MIND FOR SOME OF THE
LOWER AND NURSING HOMES THIS IS
A WONDERFUL BILL. THAT WILL PUT
RESPONSIBILITY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS VOEPEL. SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ADMINISTRATION TO CLOSE IF
YOU WISH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS OF. MS AT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A AYE
AYES EIGHT SUPPORT. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR THROUGH THIRTY. PASS AND
RETAIN. THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE AB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE BY MISTER RAMOS. MEMBERS.
LET'S KEEP THE VOLUME LEVEL
MANAGEABLE MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
ATTENTION TO MISTER RAMOS
MISTER RAMOS YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY IS A
HISTORICAL VOTE THAT WILL TAKE
PLACE ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR I
INTRODUCED AB EIGHT FIVE FIVE
AT THE REQUEST OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MISTER RAMOS MY AIR.
IF YOU ALLOW ME TO HAVE THE
CLERK READ THE ITEM AND THEN
YOU MAY PROCEED MY APOLOGIES.
ASSEMBLY FIFTY FIVE IS MY RAMIS
ANOTHER IS NOT GOING TO COURTS
THIS RAMIS YOU MAY NOW PROCEED
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. TODAY IS A HISTORICAL
VOTE THAT WILL TAKE PLACE ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. I
INTRODUCED AB EIGHT FIVE FIVE
AT THE REQUEST OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. IT WOULD ESTABLISH FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY A BRANCH OF CALIFORNIA
TO HONOR CALIFORNIA NATIVEAMERICAN DAY AS A PAID HOLIDAY.
WITHOUT INCREASING THE NUMBER.
OF PAID HALL. IN THE STATE. CAN
NATIVE A DAY IS ALL HAS HALL.
BUT NOT A PAID HOLIDAY IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. I
LOBBIED DANIS. JO BACA TO IN.
AB NINETEEN THREE THE WAS
SIGNED IN LAW BY PETE WILSON.
THE FOR FRIDAY SO. THAT'S
CALIFORNIA NAY A DAY AND TODAY
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS A CHANCE
TO MOVE FORWARD CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY AS A PAID
HOLIDAY FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
pTHAN TWENTY YEARS I HAVE WORKED
TOWARDS CREATING A PAID STATE
HOLIDAY TO RECOGNIZE AND LEARN
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LIKE MANY OF THE
ROADS AND HIGHWAYS THAT WE
TRAVEL WHERE ONCE ONLY INDIAN
TRAIL IN IN MY DISTRICT AND
RENDON'S. THE INDIAN PEOPLE
THERE SERRANO COOL WE AGAIN.
ALL DONE THE HOW DID TO BRING.
INTO THIS OF RED TO SEE THAT
SAID FLORIDA WITH THE AGRIC
THAT TODAY. I WANT TO THANK THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOR BRINGING
THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD BECAUSE
BUTTE CALIFORNIA'S NO MUCH
ABOUT THE STATE'S NATIVE
AMERICAN HISTORY AND CULTURE
DESPITE THE FACT THAT OUR STATE
HAS MORE NATIVE AMERICANS
LIVING HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE NATION. THIS BILL WILL
MOVE FORWARD AS A FIRST STEP IN
CORRECTING THAT OUR MISSION. OF
THAT HISTORY. I WANT RIGHT I
WOULD NOW LIKE TO SAY. AS A
CALIFORNIA IN THE PERSON. AND
HISTORY THAT'S BEING DONE HERE
ON THIS FLOOR THE FIRST
GOVERNOR PUT OUT BOUNTIES ON
THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE AND THAT
LEGISLATURE BACK THEN
REIMBURSED THOSE MILITIAS FOR
KILLING INDIAN PEOPLE. TODAY WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO MOVE FORWARD
SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT AND
START TO EDUCATE THE PEOPLE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MISTER ROBERTS MR GARCIA IN
THE REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
AND- MAYBE CANNOT MATCH THE
PASSION THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
JUST. DISPLAYED BUT CERTAINLY
FEEL- THE HONOR OF US TAKING
THIS ACTION TODAY AS HE HAS
ARTICULATED QUITE WELL. IN OUR
GOVERNOR AND HIS FIRST YEAR IN
OFFICE I TOOK A REALLY BOLD
ACTION AND IT WAS REALLY A LONG
TIME COMING AND THAT WAS
RECOGNIZING. THE ROLE THAT THE
STATE A CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT
PLAYED. IN HOW IT TREATED
NATIVE AMERICANS HERE IN OUR
AND OUR STATE AND HE
ACKNOWLEDGES THE FACT THAT WE
HAD A LOT OF WORK TO DO- TO
BRINGING OUR- FIRST PEOPLES TO
THE FRONT OF SAN. OF POP PUBLIC
POLICY MAKING THAT TAKES PLACE
HERE TO ENSURE THE NOT JUST THE
HISTORY IS A FORGOTTEN BUT THAT
WE ALSO TAKE ACTIONS. TO ENSURE
THAT OPPORTUNITIES CONTINUE TO
BE PRESENTED TO ALL TRIBES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA YOU SEE MANY
TIMES WHEN WE THINK OF
CALIFORNIA NATIVE TRIBES DO WE
JUST THINK OF ONE THING- AND WE
PASSED BY THERE WE ASSUME. THAT
ALL IS GOOD AT ALL AS WELL BUT
THE FACT IS THAT THERE ARE MANY
TRIBES. THAT REMAIN VOICELESS
THERE MANY TRIBES THAT LIVE ON
INDIAN RESERVATIONS. WITH NO
CLEAN WATER. WE FROM AMOUNT
SOCIAL THAT ARE IMPACT COULD-
COVER NINETEEN HIT THE
EXTREMELY HARD AS WELL AS MANY
THE OTHER. OF COLOR. AND SO BY
US TAKING THIS ACTION. EVEN IN
THE SPACE OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND MAKING THIS A PAID
HOLIDAY WE'RE RECOGNIZING. THE
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE DESERVING OF
THIS TYPE OF ACKNOWLEDGEMENT SO
I WANT TO JUST. COMMEND THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE MEASURES THAT HE
BRINGS FORWARD BECAUSE WHAT IT
DOES. IS THAT HE'S EDUCATING
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US ON THE
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA FIRST
PEOPLES. THANK YOU AGAIN AND I
RISE. IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CAR. MISTER GABRIEL YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RE AND SUPPORT OF
AB **** FIVE FIVE ON AS CHAIR
THE CALIFORNIA LAW. YOUR CAUCUS
I WANNA. ECHO THE THANK TO THE
ALL FOR BRINGING THIS REALLY
MEASURE FOR. IN ALL OF
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT HE HAS
DONE. GIVING VOICE TO HIS
COMMUTE AND OUR FIRST PEOPLE TO
THE FIRST CAL. WE HAVE THE ON.
TO HAVE HIM COME IN TO ARGUE
COPY THIS PASS WEEKEND WE A
VERY PER. X. ABOUT. WE'RE GONNA
LATER TODAY ABOUT THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE. WE SPOKE A FEW WEEKS
AGO ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST BUT WE
DON'T OFTEN TALK ABOUT ENOUGH
IS THE GENOCIDE THAT WAS
COMMITTED AGAINST OUR- NATIVE
AMERICANS HERE AGAINST OUR
CALIFORNIA INDIANS. MUCH OF IT
WITH THE LINKS TO THIS BUILDING
TO THIS BODY AND TO THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. AND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TO
ELEVATING THAT HISTORY THERE'S
A LOT THAT MEMBERS OF OUR
CONGRESS OUR CAUCUS LEARNED IN
OUR BRIEF CONGRESS CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR. I JUST WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR THE WORK THAT HE
IS DOING TO HELP EDUCATE ALL
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUES ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF. AND THE JEWISH CAUCUS
WOULD URGE AN. AYE VOTE ON AB
EIGHT FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER. MISTER RIVAS AND THE
ROAD CHAMBER YOUR RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
RIDE IT IS SUPPORT FOR THE
IMPORTANT. ONE OF OUR- FROM
FROM HIGHLAND FOR. MAKING SURE
THAT HE BROUGHT THIS FORWARD IN
YOUR AS AS WE'VE HEARD THIS
LEGISLATION. WILL MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY A JUDICIAL HOLIDAY IN LIEU
OF COLUMBUS DAY. AND IN THIS
WAY THIS BILL FURTHERS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S MISSION. AS
EMBODIED IN THE COUNCIL
STRATEGIC PLAN TO QUOTE REMOVE
ALL BARRIERS TO ACCESS
FAIRNESS. BY BE RESPONSIVE TO
THE STATE'S CULTURAL ETHNIC
SOCIAL ECONOMIC LINGUISTIC
PHYSICAL GENDER AND AGE. THE
DIVERSE CITIES AND TO ALL
PEOPLE. THIS LEGISLATION AB
EIGHT FIVE FIVE HONORS THE RICH
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CULTURAL
HERITAGE OF OUR NATIVE AMERICAN
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS. INDEED
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION IN
THE COUNTRY. WITH A HUNDRED TEN
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
LOCATED ACROSS OUR STATE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE ON A DAY
TO CELEBRATE THIS IS THAT THE
DIVERSE- THE TAPESTRY OF
HISTORY AND- SOME TRADITIONS
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT OUR
CHILDREN HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY
ONCE A YEAR TO LEARN ABOUT THE
IMPORTANT HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE.
RECOGNIZING AND HONORING
CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE PEOPLES AND
CULTURES AND HISTORIES IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S FOR THAT
REASON I RESPECTFULLY URGE AND
I VOTE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS. SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM MISTER
RAMOS YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU TO THOSE
PASSIONATE SPEECHES AND TODAY
IS A FIRST STEP IN RECOGNIZING
AND EDUCATING THE STATE ON
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE. AND WITH THAT
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT. THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE
YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS THIRTY TWO
THROUGH THIRTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT
IS AB TWELVE TEN BY MR TANG
CORKERY ASSIGNMENTS WALTON BY
SOME EMERGINGACCORDING TO
PEARL MISTER KING YOU MAY OPEN
THANK FOR TO SPEAK CAL DOES NOT
PRESENTLY REQUIRE ANY
PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE ON THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
COMMISSIONERS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THEY ARE MAKING CRITICAL
DECISIONS. IMPACTING THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS HAS SEVENTEEN FULL
TIME COMMISSIONERS ARE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR
EXISTING LAW CURRENTLY MANDATES
THAT THESE COMMISSIONERS SHOULD
REFLECT ACCURATE CROSS SECTION
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELDS THAT
INCLUDE SOCIOLOGY MEDICINE AND
MENTAL HEALTH HOWEVER AT THIS
TIME NONE OF THOSE FIELDS ARE
ACTUALLY REPRESENT. AB TWELVE
TEN REQUIRED THAT BY JULY FIFTH
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AT LEAST
TEN COMMISSIONERS ON THE BORDER
PATROL HEARINGS ACCURATE
REPRESENT COMING FROM THE
FOLLOWING BACKGROUND A MEDICAL
DOCTOR WITH EXPERIENCE WORKING
WITH GERIATRIC PATIENTS A
PSYCHOLOGIST OR PSYCHIATRIST
HAS BEEN EXPERIENCED IN WORKING
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA THE SOCIAL
WORKER WHO'S WORKED WITH
INDIVIDUALS WERE BEEN ACROSS
RIGHT BY THEIR FAMILIES A DRUG
TREATMENT COUNSELOR. PERSON
WITH THE NONPROFIT BACKGROUND.
IN RECENT SERVICES AN ATTORNEY.
TO SUPPORT IN TO BE WITHIN
FOUR. AND NUMER OTHER PARTS.
WITHOUT RESPECT FOR YOU RIVA
FOR A BI. TWELVE TO. THANK YOU
MISTER TANK. SEEING DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB
RURAL. MEMBERS. OUT A VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
OUT. HIGHS FIFTY ONE THOSE
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY NINE THROUGH
FORTY THREE. PASS RETAIN. FILE
ITEM FORTY FOUR IS AB FORTINO
TO BY MR LEVINE CORKERY
ASSIGNABLE FORTINO TO BUY SOME
ERROR LEVINE AND ACCORDING TO
TAXATION. MR LEVINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FORTINO TOO WILL
REQUIRE A MARKETPLACE
FACILITATOR TO REGISTER COLLECT
AND REMIT ALL APPLICABLE FEES
REQUIRED TO BE ADMINISTERED
UNDER THE FEE COLLECTION
PROCEDURES LAW. CURRENTLY OUT
OF STATE BUSINESSES ARE GETTING
AWAY WITHOUT DOING SOMETHING
THAT OUR BRICK AND MORTAR
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
REQUIRED TO DO AND WITH AN
INCREASED USE OF E. COMMERCE
RETAIL PURCHASES ONLINE
RETAILERS. HAVE SHIFTED TO
SELLING THEIR PRODUCTS TO
PLATFORMS CALLED MARKETPLACE
FACILITATORS WE WILL NOW JOIN
OTHER STATES LIKE ARKANSAS.
NORTH DAKOTA. VIRGINIA NORTH
CAROLINA UTAH THAT ALREADY DO
THIS CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY LATE
IN THE GAME TO COLLECTING THESE
FEES ON THINGS LIKE LEAD ACID
BATTERIES ON TIRES WE CAN
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMPANIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
ARE ON ETHICAL GROUNDS OF THE
OUT OF STATE COMPANIES ARE SET
TO ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MR
LEVINE. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. THE CLUB THEY'RE ALL
MEMBERS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. DESIRABLE. THE CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
SEVEN NO SIXTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS FORTY FIVE
FORTY SIX AND FORTY SEVEN PASS.
AND RETAIN WHERE FILE ITEM
FORTY EIGHT THIS IS A C. R.
SIXTY FOUR BY MR FONG THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY FOUR BY
SOMEWHERE FONG ANOTHER'S
RELATIVE TO THE HARVEY L. HALL
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY MR FONG EMAIL
BUT- I THINK IT WAS A SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ACR SIXTY FOUR. ACR SIXTY FOUR
WOULD DESIGNATE A PORTION OF
THE WEBSITE PARKWAY ON STATE
ROUTE FIFTY EIGHT. AS THE
HARVEY L. HALL MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY. IS A PIONEER OF MODERN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES AND
BAKERSFIELD LONGEST SERVING
MAYOR HARVEY L. HALL EMBRACE
HIS MOTTO OF. UNITY IN OUR
COMMUNITY WITH A LIFETIME OF
SERVICE TO KERN COUNTY. MISTER
HAWES IMPACTFUL CAREER STARTED
AT JUST NINETEEN YEARS OLD WHEN
HE WAS THERE TO GO ON A RIDE
ALONG WITH THE LOCAL AMBULANCE
DRIVER. PICKING IS INTEREST IN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE IN FURTHER
DEVELOPING INTO A FIFTY EIGHT
YEAR CAREER OF SERVICE. WITH A
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLAR BANK
LOAN AND THE VISION TO BUILD
THE BEST AMBULANCE COMPANY IN
THE NATION. HARVEY HALL FOUNDED
HALL AMBULANCE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE. WHICH IS RESIDENTS
SERVING AS HEADQUARTERS FOR
SHORT YEARS LATER MISTER HALL
INTRODUCED THE FIRST MOBILE
INTENSIVE CARE PARAMEDIC
PROGRAM IN KERN COUNTY. AND
LATER LAUNCHED FALL AIR
AMBULANCE IN HALL CRITICAL CARE
TRANSPORT PROVIDING LIFE SAVING
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE AND
SERVICES BOTH ON THE GROUND AND
IN THE AIR. TODAY HALL
INFLUENCERS MUCH OF KERN
COUNTY'S POPULATION AS A
CRITICAL NINE ONE ONE A
PARAMEDIC PROVIDER. MAYOR HOLES
HEART FOR SERVICE WAS EVIDENT
THROUGHOUT HIS LEADERSHIP. AS
MAYOR HARVEY HALL FOCUS ON
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION AND
NEVER MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HONOR AND SUPPORT OUR VETERANS
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ALIKE. HE WAS A
TREMENDOUS CHEERLEADER FOR THE
BIGGEST OUR COMMUNITY. TO
COMMEMORATE THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF ALL INFLUENCE
THE HARVEY L. HALL MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY HONORS HIS LEGACY OF
COMPASSION. MENTORSHIP
INNOVATION GENEROSITY AND
SERVICE ABOVE SELF. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MISS FONG MR
SOUTH. YOU ARE. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AC ARE SIXTY FOUR
YOU KNOW I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
SERVING ALONGSIDE A MISTER
HARVEY HALL. WHO WAS A GREAT
PUBLIC SERVICE SERVICE BUT ALSO
THE LONGEST SERVING MAYOR. AND
THE CITY OF BAKERSFIELD I ONE
OF THE THINGS I APPRECIATED
ABOUT MISTER HALL WAS HIS QUOTE
WAS ALWAYS UNITY IN THE
COMMUNITY. THERE WAS JUST ONE
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD
WALK AROUND TOWN AND THESE OLD
SANDWICH BOARDS. YOU KNOW
PROFESSING UNITY IN THE
COMMUNITY AND ASKING EVERYONE
TO GO OUT AND VOTE ONE OF THE
THINGS I REALLY APPRECIATED
ABOUT HIM. WAS EVEN DESPITE.
HIS PARTY AT THE TIME YEARS AGO.
HE MARCHED WITH US FOR
IMMIGRATION MARCH RALLY IN THE
CITY OF BAKERSFIELD I KNOW WE
CAUGHT FLAK A LITTLE BIT FROM
HIS. FROM HIS AT POLITICAL
PARTY BUT HE TRULY BELIEVED IN
UNITY IN THE COMMUNITY AND SO I
AM PROUD TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF
ACR SIXTY FOUR. I THINK IT'S
ONLY FITTING THAT WE PROVIDE
THIS MEMORIAL RESOLUTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CELIS.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION MR FONG YOU MAY
CLOSE WE WISH I JUST WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD- FOR HIS HIS
REMARKS A MAYOR HALL AS A
MENTOR TO A LOT OF US AND I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT. WAY TO
HONOR HIS LEGACY AND I WAS
ASKED WHEN I FELT. IMAGE FONG
IS LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION YES PLEASE. FIRST
ALL THE FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS
CLICK OVER THERE ALL. CO
AUTHORS ON ACR SIXTY FOUR THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ON THE
RESOLUTION. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE SEVENTY FOUR
CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FORTY NINE ACR FOR
THE CORPORATE. SOME ATTACKERS
CONCURRENTLY XIN FOR BY SUMMER
WHEN MILITANTS OF BLACK APRIL
MORE A MONTH. MISTER WHEN YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ACR FOR
AND TO COMMEMORATE BLACK APRIL
MEMORIAL MONTH. TODAY I PROUDLY
STAND HERE TO REMEMBER AN EVENT
THAT CHANGED THE LIVES OF
MILLIONS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
THE COLOURS I'M WEARING TO
REPRESENTS A FREE AND
DEMOCRATIC VIETNAM. AT THIS
TIME I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK IT WOULD TAKE
A MOMENTS SILENCE TO RECOGNIZE
OUR VETERANS WITH A MOMENT OF
SILENCE FOR THEIR SELFLESS
SERVICE DURING THE VIETNAM WAR
IN FOR THEIR BRAVE FIGHT FOR
DEMOCRACY. THANK YOU. FORTY SIX
YEARS AGO MY FAMILY MADE THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO LEAVE
EVERYTHING BEHIND. AS SAIGON
FELL TO COMMUNIST FORCES ON
APRIL THIRTIETH NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. MY FAMILY AND
MILLIONS OF ENEMIES FLED
VIETNAM IN SEARCH OF FREEDOM
AND DEMOCRACY. BLACK APRIL AND
THE FALL OF SAIGON CHANGED THE
COURSE OF MILLIONS OF LIVES
INCLUDING MINE. BY DECLARING
THE MONTH OF APRIL AS BLACK
APRIL MORE A MONTH WE PROVIDE
VINNIE'S AMERICANS. VETERANS OF
THE ARMED FORCES AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GATHER HONOR EVERY PLOT FLECKED
UPON THE VIETNAM WAR AND ITS
AFTERMATH. MANY OF MANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS HERE TODAY SHARES
LIVES LIKE MINE A COMING TO
AMERICA IN SEARCH OF FREEDOM
AND DEMOCRACY. AFTER ESCAPING
THE CALMEST GOVERNMENT BIT NAM.
WE KNEW THAT OUR FUTURE IN
VIETNAM WAS G
DIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES ALIKE
MADE THE DIFFICULT CHOICE TO
RISK OUR LIVES TO ESCAPE. TWO
OF THE NATION'S. TODAY WE ARE
ALL GRATEFUL FOR THE INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CALIFORNIA
AND THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA HAVE PRESENTED. TO US
OP TUESDAY WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE TO US IF WE HAD
NOT ESCAPED AT NAM. AS WE
CONTINUE TO STRIVE TO ACHIEVE
THE AMERICAN DREAM IN OUR OWN
LIVES WE NEED TO REMEMBER AND
TO CONTINUE TO PROMOTE FREEDOM.
AND DEMOCRACY THROUGHOUT THE
WAR IT IS A SPECIALLY CRITICAL
THAT WE- THAT WE REMIND BABY.
THAT WE REMAIN MINDFUL OF THE
CURRENT SITUATION VIETNAM AND I
WOULD URGE THE GOVERNMENT THE
SOCIALIST REPUBLIC OF NOT BEEN
NON. TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
ITS CITIZENS. WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT THOUSANDS OF BRAVE
SOLDIERS AND CIVILIANS WHO LOST
THEIR LIVES IN THE BRAVE AND
YORK FIGHT FOR FREEDOM. WE MUST
TEACH OUR CHILDREN. AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS IMPORTANT LESSONS
OF THE VIETNAM WAR AS WELL AS
THE CURRENT SITUATION IN
VIETNAM. IN CLOSING I WOULD
LIKE TO COURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
IN ALL CALIFORNIANS. TO USE
THIS DESTINATION AS A PLATFORM
TO EDUCATE AND RAISE AWARENESS
OF OUR JOINT HISTORY WITH
VIETNAM AND IMPORTANCE OF THE
PRINCIPLE OF FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY THROUGHOUT THE WAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISS WHEN MR DALY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION. AFTER THE
VIETNAM WAR MANY SEEKING
FREEDOM FOUND REFUGE HERE IN
AMERICA ORANGE COUNTY BECAME A
POPULAR SPOT FOR SETTLEMENT
FAMILIES WERE STARTED IN SMALL
BUSINESSES WERE CREATED AND
COMMUNITIES WERE TRANSFORMED.
SADLY NOT EVERYONE WHO MADE THE
JOURNEY SURVIVED AND WE MUST
NEVER FORGET THEIR SACRIFICE. I
STAND ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUES
IN SOMBER REFLECTION OF BLACK
APRIL AND IN RECOGNITION OF ALL
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THE
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY HAS GIVEN
OUR STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER DALY MISTER KALRA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU LAKE
MICHIGAN MEMBERS IT'S- WITH THE
IS AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO STAND
HERE AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR- TELLING HER
FAMILY'S STORY- I'VE HEARD MANY
LIKE IT BUT I KNOW EACH ONE
EVEN THOUGH- THERE'S A LOT OF
COMMONALITY EACH ONE WAS A
STRUGGLE IN ITSELF AND THE
PERSEVERANCE AND PERSISTENCE.
AND STRENGTH. THAT HAS BEEN
SHOWN BY SO MANY OF OUR
VIETNAMESE. AMERICAN BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AND I AM HONORED TO
REPRESENT. THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
WHICH HAS THE LARGEST.
POPULATION OF ANYONE CITY
OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM. I MOVED TO
SAN JOSE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. AND IT WAS DURING THAT
TIME AND IN THE YEARS OF FOLLOW
UP AND BEFORE BILL THESE WHEN I
CAME I WAS NOTICING AS A SMALL
CHILD. A LOT OF YOUNG
VIETNAMESE KIDS WERE JOINING
EVERY YEAR TO BE MORE AND MORE
COMING TO OUR SCHOOLS.
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL GOING ON IN
THE MIDDLE SCHOOL. AND I THINK
BACK DURING THAT TIME IN
RETROSPECT CAN JUST ONLY
IMAGINE HOW HARD IT WAS. FOR
THOSE CHILDREN TO COME TO A NEW
COUNTRY. ALREADY HAVING GONE
WITH THEIR FAMILIES TO SO MUCH
CHAOS AND TRAUMA JUST TO ARRIVE
ON OUR SHORES. AND TO NOT ONLY
SHOW THE PERSEVERANCE AND THE
WILLINGNESS TO MAKE IT IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS THEIR FOR AS THEIR
PARENTS WERE OPENING UP SMALL
BUSINESSES WERE DOING WHATEVER
IT TOOK WE HAD AT THE TIME OF
THE LARGEST FLEA MARKET IN THE
COUNTRY AND SO MANY OF OUR
VIETNAMESE NEIGHBORS. OF NOTE
WERE DOING WHATEVER IT TOOK
SELLING THINGS AT THE FLEA
MARKET AND AS THE YEARS WENT
ON- NOW SOME OF THE- BEST
ENTREPRENEURS AND BUSINESS
OWNERS WE HAVE CERTAINLY- IN
SAN JOSE IN THE SILICON VALLEY.
OUR VISION IS AMERICANS SECOND
THIRD GENERATION NOW- AND I
JUST WANT TO MAKE NOTE OF THIS
PAST YEAR IT'S BEEN HARD ON ALL
OF US. BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SPECIAL NOTE. OF THE NEW
VIETNAMESE. SALON OWNERS AND
WORKERS SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
THAT HAVE BEEN HIT
EXTRAORDINARILY HARD IN MY
DISTRICT AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. ALL BUT I WILL SAY THIS
ALSO IS ALL OF US- PERSEVERE
THROUGH THIS MOMENT. THAT WE
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE OF LOOKING
AT THE VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT
IT TAKES TO PERSEVERE. THROUGH
WHATEVER TRAUMA DIFFICULTIES
LIFE BRINGS OUR WAY. OF AS A
LIVING EXAMPLE. AS OF AS A
LIVING EXAMPLE OF THE- GREAT
AMERICAN STORY OF IMMIGRATION.
OF ACCEPTANCE AND OF DOING
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU PROVIDE FOR YOUR
CHILDREN AND YOUR FOR YOUR
FAMILIES AND I THINK- YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND ALL SAY YOU'LL SEE
IT HOW CLEAR. THAT IS AND- SO
IT'S AN HONOR. TO BE ABLE TO
STAND WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AND
TO REMEMBER THE SACRIFICE THAT
TOOK. THE PAIN. OF THAT IT TOOK
FOR US TO BE HERE TODAY TO BE
ABLE TO. RECOGNIZE THE STRENGTH
OF THE MUSE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA MS CLARK SILVA IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO RISE TODAY TO
STAND WITH HER VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO IN ORANGE
COUNTY WHERE I REPRESENT A
GROWING NUMBER OF UNIT
VIETNAMESE CONSTITUENTS. THIS
RESOLUTION ACR FOUR PROCLAIMS
THE MONTH OF APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS BLACK APRIL
MEMORIAL MONTH. AND APRIL
THIRTIETH NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WITH THE DAY SAIGON THE CAPITAL
OF SOUTH VIETNAM WAS CAPTURED
BY THE NORTH VIETNAMESE TROOPS.
THE DAY MARKED THE END OF THE
VIETNAM WAR AND THE
REUNIFICATION OF VIETNAM AND
YOU WANT TO. COUNTY THE
SOCIALIST REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM.
THIS IS NOT A CELEBRATION DAY
FOR THE FAMILIES OF SOUTH
VIETNAM WHERE THE DAY IS KNOWN
AS THING TO DONE OR BLACK
FRIDAY. FOR VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS THE WEEK OF APRIL
THIRTIETH IS COME OUT
COMMEMORATED AS A TIME OF
REFLECTION FOR THE FALL OF
SAIGON AND THE FALL OF SOUTH
VIETNAM. BUT IT'S ALSO A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE AND REDEDICATION TO
THE PRINCIPLES OF FREEDOM
FREEDOM OF RELIGION AND THAT
END OF OPPRESSION. MY FRIENDS
THE STORY IS ABOUT OUR
COLLEAGUE IN HER FAMILY WHO
CAME OVER WITH MUCH TRAUMA BUT
IT'S ALSO THE STORY OF MANY OF
OUR FRIENDS AND FAMILIES WHO.
COME TO OUR COUNTRY ON PLANES
ACROSS BORDERS. ALL FOR THE
SAME REASON. TO SEEK FREEDOM
AND JUSTICE AND DEMOCRACY SO WE
STAND WITH YOU TODAY. BUT WE
STAND WITH ALL OF THOSE WHO
COME TO OUR COUNTRY FOR WHAT WE
ALL HAVE WHICH IS FREEDOM AND
JUSTICE. I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR ACR FOR. THANK YOU MISS
CLARK SILVA MR MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNZED FOR ME DESK THANK
YOU ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM GARDEN GROVE-
FOR RECOGNIZING FORTY SIX YEARS
THE FALL OF SAIGON AND ITS
IMPACT ON OUR GREAT STATE AS I
AS I'VE TOLD OUR CALLER BEFORE
I WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL HERE
FOR TEN YEARS IN SACRAMENTO.
AND ONE OF MY FONDEST MEMORIES
WAS AND I CREATED A LOOK THE
LITTLE SAIGON DISTRICT ALONG
STOCKTON BOULEVARD AT THAT TIME
WE HAD NEVER FILLED OUR CITY
COUNCIL CHAMBERS FRED OVERFLOW
WE HAD SO MANY PROUD MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMUNITY NOT QUITE LIKE
SAN JOSE IN OUR GARDEN GROVE.
OR SAN FRANCISCO BUT ONE OF THE
LARGE VIETNAMESE MERICAN
REFUGEE LOCATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE PRIDE THAT WE SAW THAT
DAY AND WE CAN SEE UP AND DOWN
STOCKTON BOULEVARD TODAY WERE
LITTLE SAIGON DISTRICT IS NO
SIGNIFICANT AND SO. THE TRAUMA
IN TWO YEARS- THE MEMORIES ARE
THERE BUT THE FAMILIES
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THIS AND VALUE- WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND TO PROMOTING DEMOCRACY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU AND-
I APPRECIATE A CA. FOR THANK
YOU. AMOS MCCARTY MISTER VOEPEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR
DESK. MISTER SPEAKER IN
COLLEAGUES. I'M THE LAST
VIETNAM VETERAN TO PROBABLY
SERVE IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE ONLY ONE RIGHT NOW. SO
I MUST RELATED TO YOU THE
HEARTBREAK OF MANY VETERANS FOR
BLACK APRIL. BEFORE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WE REALLY THOUGHT
WE WERE WINNING THE WAR. AND
THE VIETNAMESE WERE FIGHTING
HARD AND GOOD. AFTER NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT THINGS ON RAVEL.
AND WHEN YOU GOT SENT TO
VIETNAM WITHIN THREE TO FIVE
WEEKS YOU KNEW YOU WERE
FIGHTING A LOSING WAR. SO DID
THE SOUTH VIETNAMESE ARMY NAVY
AND AIR FORCE. BUT WE FOUGHT WE
FOUGHT HARD. WE DID OUR BEST.
SO ALL THE SOUTH VIETNAMESE.
VETERANS AND ALL THE AMERICAN
VETERANS. WHEN WE SAW THAT TANK
BUSTS THROUGH THE GATE. OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL PALACE. WE CRIED
IN OUR HEARTS BROKE. SO. MISTER
SPEAKER THAT'S MY WORDS. THANK
YOU MR VOEPEL. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION MISTER WHEN YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TO MY COLLEAGUES. WELCOME HOME.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE SACRIFICE
YOU'VE MADE BECAUSE I WILL TELL
YOU THIS LITTLE CHILD COULD NOT
BE IN THIS GREAT COUNTRY WHAT A
WHAT YOU AND THE FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND AMERICANS DID IN
VIETNAM FOR US ON OUR BEHALF. A
YES I GET EMOTIONAL TO THIS DAY
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS MONTH-
BECAUSE OF YOUR SACRIFICE. AND
THE THOUSANDS TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS AND THE THOUSANDS
OF ENEMIES. WE VILLAINY'S WOULD
NOT BE HERE WITHOUT THE SUPPORT.
AND THE FIGHT THE G. GAVE FOR
US IN VIETNAM FOR THE DEMOCRACY
AND THE FREEDOM. THAT THAT
COUNTRY HAD. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SAN JOSE AND SACRAMENTO FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND STANDING
BEHIND THE VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN YOUR RESPECTIVE.
AREAS IT TRULY MEANS A LOT TO
US. IT MIGHT NOT IT MIGHT JUST
BE ANOTHER DAY FOR SOME FOLKS
BUT IT'S NOT FOR US. IT'S A DAY
THAT WE REMEMBER. WHEN MY UNCLE
WAS EXECUTED BECAUSE HE WAS ONE
OF THE OFFICER. WHEN SAIGON
FELL MY FAMILY HAD TO RUN. I
DON'T HAVE ANY PICTURES OF
MYSELF YOUNGER THAN MY ONE
PHOTO I HAVE WHEN I WAS IN WHEN
WE LAND IN THAILAND. WHAT A
LITTLE SIGN IN FRONT OF ME- AND
WITH MY NAME AND THE NUMBER.
THAT'S THE YOUNGEST PHOTO I
HAVE OF MYSELF BECAUSE WE HAD
TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME FOR
LISTENING AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THEY MISSED WHY WOULD YOU LIKE
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
YES PLEASE FIRST ROLE THE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS FOR GLOBAL THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON A C. R. FOUR THIS IS
FOR COOPER'S.
THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
AUTHOR SEVENTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
FILE OR THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY. ACR SEVENTY THREE
QUACKERY ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY THREE BY
SEVEN- FRAZIER RELATIVE TO
AUTISM AWARENESS MONTH MR
FRAZIER EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES ACR
SEVENTY THREE DESIGNATES THE
MONTH OF APRIL AS AUTISM
AWARENESS MONTH. AND IS
INTENDED TO TEACH AWARENESS AND
ENCOURAGE SUPPORT AND
UNDERSTANDINGS FOR FRIENDS
FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORS THAT
HAVE EITHER HAVE OR LIVE WITH
THOSE WITH AUTISM. IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE CDC REPORTER THE
APPROXIMATE ONE IN FIFTY FOUR
CHILDREN IN THE UNITED STATES
IS DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM
SPECTER SPECTRUM DISORDER. THEY
ARE NOT RUSSIA SHALL BE
RELEGATED OR DISMISSED. JUST
LET ME GIVE YOU A COUPLE SYSTEM
STATISTICS AUTISM IS THE
FASTEST GROWING DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY IN THE UNITED STATES
ONE THIRTY SEVEN BOYS. ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM WELL ONE
AND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE GIRLS
ARE DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM.
AUTISM RELATED COSTS AVERAGE AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR PER FAMILY. THE
AVERAGE AGE OF DIAGNOSIS
DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM IS THAT
FOUR YEARS OF AGE BUT A CHILD
CAN BE DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM AS
EARLY AS EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
MEMBERS I'D URGE YOU IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET TO LOOK. TO
YOURSELF AND- VOTE FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION TO ADVANCE
SUCCESSES WITH CHILDREN WITH
AUTISM MAKE SURE IT'S IN THE
BUDGET. THIS IS WHERE WE'RE
GONNA BE OUR OUR BIGGEST
SUCCESSES WITH CHILDREN WHEN
THEY'RE ON THE INTERVENTION IS
EARLY. AND INSISTENT. MISTER
SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON ACR SEVEN THREE
KEEP ROLE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER MS
CALAVERAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR
SEVENTY THREE AND I THINK- THE
AUTHOR FOR PRESENTING THIS.
ABOUT TWELVE YEARS AGO I WAS
RIDING IN THE BACKOF A CAR
WITH MY MOM AND MY TWO AND A
HALF YEAR OLD NIECE. AND SHE
WAS ASLEEP IN THE BACKSEAT AND
IT WAS A HOT DAY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. MY MOM AND I WERE
TALKING WE'RE BLASTING THE AIR
CONDITIONER BECAUSE IT WAS HOT
AND WE KNEW IT WOULD MEAN IT
WOULD BE COLD IN THE CAR BUT
FOUGHT AT HOME. AND OUT OF NO
WHERE MY KNEES STARTED
SCREAMING. AND CRYING. NUMIC
MOM WHAT'S WRONG WITH HER. HE'S
LIKE I DON'T KNOW ME HOT I
REACH BACK TO COMFORT HER. AND
I FEEL RELATING. AND SHE'S
FREEZING. MY NIECE WAS
DIAGNOSED AS SEVERELY
DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED
NONVERBAL AND ON THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM. SHE HAD NOT ONE WORD
IN HER VOCABULARY SO THAT DAY
AT TWO AND A HALF YEARS OLD SHE
COULDN'T TELL ME MY MOM. NANA
I'M COLD THE A- COLD. WATCHING
HER BE DIAGNOSED GO THROUGH AN
IMMERSION OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
INTERVENTION SERVICES. OVER THE
COURSE OF A YEAR AND A HALF
THAT LITTLE GIRL WHO WAS CRYING
BECAUSE SHE WAS FREEZING IN THE
CAR. WOULD START TO TALK. AND
BOY WHEN WE LEARNED THAT SHE
NEEDED GLASSES AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME SHE COULD SEE ALL OF
THE ROOMS ON THE LITTLE HOUSES
IN A CAR RIDE. IT WAS A MIRACLE
THAT HAPPENED BEFORE MY EYES.
AND I BECOME TO BE A STRONG
VOICE FOR THE AUTISM COMMUNITY
BECAUSE WELL MY KNEES HAD MY
MOM AND MYSELF TO BE AN
ADVOCATE FOR HER NOT EVERY
CHILD HAS ACCESS. TO EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF THESE
SYMPTOMS AND EARLY DIAGNOSIS
AND EARLY DIAGNOSIS CHANGES
RISE CHANGES THE QUALITY OF
LIFE. BUT WE CAN'T FORGET BUT
IT'S NOT JUST CHILDREN THAT
HAVE AUTISM AUTISM THERE IS NO
CURE. I HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN FORTY FIVE YEARS OLD THAT
CALL ME AND TELL ME THEY WERE
RECENTLY DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM.
IS A SPECTRUM DISORDER IT IS A
LIFETIME DISORDER IT'S NOT
SIMPLY ABOUT EARLY CHILDHOOD
DIAGNOSIS AND AWARENESS IT'S
ABOUT ACCESS TO RESOURCES IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE IT'S ABOUT
HOUSING AND TRANSITION IT'S
ABOUT PLANNING FOR WHEN THEIR
PARENTS DIED. WELL THEY KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEIR CHILDREN
IS A COMMUNITY THAT WE HAVE TO
CELEBRATE IS A COMMUNITY THAT
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR COMMUNITY.
IT IS A COMMUNITY THAT WE
CELEBRATE BUT WE CANNOT. IGNORE
THEIR CHALLENGES AND WE
EVERYONE OF US IN THIS ROOM HAS
THE POWER TO MAKE THE LIFE OF
AN INDIVIDUAL ON THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM AND THEIR FAMILIES A
PRIORITY BY PROVIDING
RESOURCES. I STRONGLY URGE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS WELL THERE'S
MISTER GIBSON IN THE REAR
CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I WAS NOT-
SCHEDULED TO- SPEAK ON THIS ON
THIS ITEM ACR SEVENTY THREE BUT
I WANT TO THANK THE GENTLEMAN
FROM- FAIRFIELD ONE STANDING
UP. STANDING UP ALWAYS
COURAGEOUS IS I'VE BEEN ON THIS
FLOOR YOU'VE ALWAYS CHAMPION
THE CALLS THOSE WHO ARE ON HE
SPECTRUM THOSE WHO ARE AUTISTIC
AND SERGIO VOICES HAVE BEEN
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR IN THIS
HALL IN THIS CHAMBERS. THE
STANDING UP OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS I THINK WE SEARCH
OUR OWN FAMILIES WILL FIND
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE ON THE
SPECTRUM OR OR OUR CHILDREN
LIVING WITH AND HAVEN'T BEEN
DIAGNOSED ANDCERTAINLY THIS
ACR- REALLY SPEAKS TO OF THE
VERY FACTTHAT WHILE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS IN THE
FOREFRONT WE LOOK AT- EVEN
AROUND. OF A JUST AS AN
INDIVIDUALS ENCOUNTERING LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN TERMS THE
TRAINING- IDENTIFYING
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE AUTISM AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS A PART OF OUR SUBJECT
TO THIS PART OF OUR AGENDA. AND
I SIMPLY WANT TO AT LEAST A
LINE MY COMMENTS WHAT IS
ALREADY BEEN SET UP FROM THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER BUT MOST OF
POIGNANTLY IS TO LET OF THE
GERMAN NO FROM A FAIRFIELD A
HERE'S YOUR ABSOLUTELY MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFUL I'LL STRONG I
BELIEVE. ACR SEVENTY THREE.
THANK GIVES A MR MAT YOUR-
THANK YOU MISTER SHE- MA'AM.
THE TO TAKE OUR A- ARE ALL. FOR
AUTISM FOR HIS WORK FOR THE
WORK THOSE BODY IS DONE. I
CANNOT STAND IN AGREEMENT TO
ECHO THE POINT. VENTURING WE
GET THIS BUDGET YEAR CORRECT
WHEN IT COMES TO HELPING OUR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY WHO ARE ON
THE AUTISTIC SPECTRUM. MY
OLDEST SON WHO TURNS FIFTEEN.
IS ON THE SPECTRUM. I REMEMBER
FINDING OUT. IN KINDERGARTEN
HEY THERE SOMETHING A LITTLE
WRONG WITH THEM. WHAT'S GOING
ON WHAT DOES THIS MEAN. WHAT
THOSE STRUGGLES LOOK WHY. IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT
AS A PARENT. HOW COME MY KID
DOESN'T TALK LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE HOW COME THEY ACT A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN EVERYBODY ELSE
HOW CAN THEY THINK DIFFERENTLY
THAN EVERYBODY ELSE. OVAL DALY
YOU KNOW YOUR SON'S AUTISTIC SO
HE'S HE'S KIND OF LIKE THIS AND
WE'RE KINDA LIKE THAT. IN
TRYING TO FIGURE THIS PIECE OUT
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS. ORDER A
BROKEN SYSTEM. AND MEMBERS IF
I'M- MYSELF AS A MEMBER. HAS TO
STRUGGLE THROUGH THIS. THINK OF
ALL OUR FAMILIES OUT THERE.
THINK ABOUT THE AUTISTIC KIDS
THE ADULTS WHO DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH WHO DON'T SPEAK AT ALL.
WE DON'T HAVE THE SAME FAMILY
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. MOVIES BUDGET
ITEMS FROM ALL. I HOPE YOUR
FINGERS THE VOTE. VOTE FOR YOUR
HARD TO TELL YOU AND YOU GET
THEM THE FUNDING THEY NEED ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MATHIS SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION. THE AUTHORS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. THE MISTER
FRAZIER WANNA GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
THIS IS A LOVING BODY ABOUT
HUMANITY WE'RE ALL SUPPOSED TO
BE HERE TO REPRESENT HUMANITY
IN THE HUMAN WELL BEING. ONE OF
THOSE POPULATIONS THAT ARE
STATE. HAS BEEN UNDER FUNDED
UNDER RECOGNIZED AND RELEGATED
TO ANOTHER AREA OF CONCERN OR
LESSER CONCERN. AND I JUST HOPE
THAT WE COME TO A POINT WHERE
WE RECOGNIZE BUT I'VE SAID THIS
BEFORE HISTORICALLY WE'RE
SPENDING THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
LESS PURSUE INDIVIDUAL WITH I.
D. D. THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
LESS. NOW AND WE WERE SPENDING
IN NINETEEN NINETY. AND THAT'S
NOT COUNTING INFLATION. MEMBERS
LET'S MAKE THIS TO YOUR
PRIORITY FOR THE FOLKS WITH IDG
SILVA DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. I REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRAZIER WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR CO AUTHORS CRITICAL OF THE
ROLE. AUTHORS ON A SECURE
SEVENTY THREE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION. CLICK WELL
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY THREE
CO AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO. H.
R. TWENTY ONE CORKERY. HOUSE
RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE BY
SOMEONE IS ERIN RELATIVE TO THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. MISTER
NAZARIAN EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE FOR
SIGNIFICANT OCCASION I'VE RISEN
IN THIS CHAMBER FOR THIS
OCCASION FOR THE PAST EIGHT
YEARS SINCE JOINING THIS BODY.
A PROUD DESCENDANT OF GENOCIDE
SURVIVORS I STAND HERE IN
COMMEMORATION OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE HR TWENTY ONE. OVER A
CENTURY AGO OTTOMAN RULERS USED
ARMENIA PHOBIA AS A DISTRACTION
DURING DOMESTIC STRIFE. THE
SLOWLY DYING AUTUMN IN TURKEY
IN CONJUNCTION WITH AZERBAIJANI
TRIBES INITIATED ETHNIC
CLEANSING CAMPAIGNS AND THE
FIRST MAJOR GENOCIDE OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY. THE EMPIRE
MURDERED THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ASSYRIANS SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND GREEKS. AND OVER A
CIVILIANS WERE RAPED TORTURED
POISONED BURNED ALIVE SHOT
THOSE WHO SURVIVED WERE FORCED
TO CONVERT. OR MARCH AND BE
DEPORTED INTO THE HEART OF THE
SYRIAN DESERT WHERE THEY FACED
EXTREME HEAT HUNGER. SAVAGE
ANIMALS AND CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
MY GRANDPARENTS ESCAPED AS
THEIR HOME TOWN OF SHUSHI IN
ARTS OFF WAS BURNED DOWN TO THE
GROUND. THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY NEVER HELD THE
PERPETRATORS ACCOUNTABLE AFTER
WORLD WAR ONE TURKEY FAILED TO
SO MUCH AS TO APOLOGIZE LET
ALONE PAY REPARATIONS TO THE
FAMILIES OF THE PEOPLE KILLED
AND MURDERED. THIS IS ONLY
EMBOLDENED BULLIES AROUND THE
WORLD IN THE LAST CENTURY TO
FURTHER CONTINUE THEIR
UNSPEAKABLE HORRORS WHETHER IT
BE HITLER POL POT OR OTHERS. A
CENTURY LATER IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE WORST PANDEMIC IN A HUNDRED
YEARS. AND WHILE IT WAS ALREADY
SUFFERING FROM WORST THE WORST
COVERED RATES IN THE WORLD
ARMENIA WAS HORRIFIC LEE
ATTACKED BY TURKEY AND
AZERBAIJAN. ATTEMPTING TO
FURTHER CONTINUE AN ETHNICALLY
CLEANSE INDIGENOUS ARMENIANS
FROM THEIR ANCESTRAL LANDS.
TURKEY THE SECOND LARGEST NATO
POWER DEPLOYED SYRIAN
MERCENARIES TO ATTACK ARMENIANS.
AND HELP UPGRADE AZERBAIJAN'S
OFFENSIVE SYSTEM AS WELL.
AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL VERIFY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWO VIDEOS
OF AZERBAIJANI TROOPS TORTURING
AND DECAPITATING CAPTURED
ARMENIANS AND MUTILATING THE
BODIES OF ARMENIAN MEN WHO HAD
FALLEN. IN ONE INSTANCE
COLLEAGUES A AZERBAIJANI
SOLDIER. USED A DEAD ARMENIAN
SOLDIERS CELLPHONE CALLED HIS
FAMILY. AND IT SHOWED THEM ON
LIVE FACEBOOK LIVE VIDEO HOW HE
IS THE CAPITATE BEING THAT THAT
SOLDIER. THIS IS IN THE
TWENTIETH SAID TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY THIS IS LAST YEAR. LAST
FALL. THE YEAR BEFORE THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN I
TRAVELED FROM. CALIFORNIA TO
STEPANAKERT THE ARTS OF THE
CAPITAL OF ARTS OFF TO ATTEND
AN INTERNATIONAL PEACE
CONFERENCE CO SPONSORED BY
ARMENIA AND ARTSAKH. THE
BUILDING THAT HOSTED MYSELF
SEVERAL OTHER CALIFORNIA.
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY INTERNATIONAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS. WAS
BOMBED BY AZERBAIJAN JUST LAST
YEAR THE VERY BUILDING THAT
HOSTED ALL OF US. A TINY
INDIGENOUS COUNTRY LANDLOCKED
BETWEEN TWO HOSTILE POWERS
ARMENIA LOST FIVE THOUSAND
SOLDIERS AND FIVE HUNDRED
CIVILIANS LAST YEAR. TO PUT
THIS INTO PERSPECTIVE IMAGINE
IF NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND AMERICANS WERE KILLED
IN A WAR IN THE MIDDLE OF
COVERED NINETEEN IN A MATTER OF
FORTY FOUR DAYS. NO ONE CAN BE
SURPRISED WHEN THE ATTACK THE
REGION'S ONLY THRIVING GROWING
DEMOCRACY. EMBOLDENED BY A LACK
OF REPERCUSSIONS TURKEY AND
AZERBAIJAN CONTINUALLY SEEK NEW
WAYS TO DESTROY THE INJURED THE
INDIGENOUS ARMENIAN PEOPLE. THE
GENOCIDE HAS NOT ENDED FOREIGN
UNIONS GREEKS AND ASSYRIANS AS
THEIR BELLIGERENT NEIGHBORS
CONTINUE TO THREATEN THEIR
EXISTENCE WITH COMMENTS SUCH AS
AN AZERBAIJANI OFFICIALS
SAYING. THEIR GOAL IS TO
COMPLETE ELIMINATION OF
ARMENIANS. AND AZERIS THE STATE
SPOKESPERSON HOPE THAT THERE
WILL BE NO STATE OF ARMENIA.
OTHER BY JOHN HAS DESTROYED
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF UNESCO
PROTECTED ARMENIAN CROSS STONES.
WHILE MANY OF US FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE TURKEY HAS DRIVEN A
CAMPAIGN OF DENIAL IT PUNISHES
TURKISH CITIZEN ITS OWN
CITIZENS WHO DARE TELL
KNOWLEDGE THE CRIMES COMMITTED
BY THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE IN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN IN FACT IT HAS
LAWS THAT IMPRISON ANYONE
MAKING ANTI TURKISH COMMENTS.
TURKEY THREATENS OTHER
COUNTRIES FROM ACKNOWLEDGING
THE GENOCIDE IT USES A
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN TO
CONFUSE THE HISTORICAL RECORD.
HISTORICAL CONSENSUS IS CLEAR
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE HAPPENED
AND TURKEY WAS THE PERPETRATOR.
THE AUTUMN EMPIRE SEIZE NEARLY
ALL ARMENIAN PROPERTIES THE
ESTIMATED VALUE OF WHICH
AMOUNTS TO TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ON THE EVE OF WORLD WAR ONE IN
ADDITION TO PRIVATE PROPERTY
ARMENIANS LIVING IN THE OTTOMAN
EMPIRE OWNED TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY CHURCHES. FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE MONASTERIES.
ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
NINETY SIX SCHOOLS. BY THE END
OF THE WAR ONLY SIX CHURCHES
REMAIN STANDING. TODAY EASTERN
TURKEY KNOWN AS WESTERN ARMENIA.
IS WIDELY UNINHABITED FILLED
WITH ROOMS OF ARMENIAN CHURCHES
AND SCHOOLS. TURKEY OWES ITS
STATUS AS A GLOBAL SUPERPOWER
TO THE WEALTH IT STOLE FROM ITS
ARMENIAN POPULATION. IN HIS
OBERSALZBERG SPEECH A WEEK
BEFORE THE INVASION OF POLAND.
HITLER ASKED HIS NERVOUS ****
COMMANDERS WHO AFTER ALL SPEAKS
TODAY OF THE ANNIHILATION OF
THE ARMENIANS. HITLER WAS
DIRECTLY INSPIRED BY THE YOUNG
TURKS. WHO CARRIED OUT THE SAME
CRIME ONLY THIRTY YEARS PRIOR.
SINCE THEN GENOCIDE HAS
OCCURRED OFTEN AND UNOPPOSED
RWANDA CAMBODIA BOSNIA DOOR FOR
THE LIST GOES ON. YOU LIVE WITH
SELL SAID NEVER AGAIN. BECOMES
MORE THAN A SLOGAN IT'S A
PRAYER IT'S A PROMISE A VOW.
NEVER AGAIN THE GLORIFICATION
OF BASS UGLY DARK VIOLENCE. OUR
HOPE IS THAT NEVER AGAIN DO WE
HAVE TO SAY NEVER AGAIN. WE
MUST ALL WORK TO PROTECT ONE
ANOTHER AND STOP THE CYCLE OF
GENOCIDE. TODAY I AM NO LONGER
ABLE TO TRAVEL TO VISIT MY HOME
ROUTES AND SHUSHI ARTS OF.
HERE'S AGO WITH OTHER MEMBERS
OF THIS VERY CHAMBER. I TRAVEL
TO ARE TOUGH AND ATTEMPTED TO
FIND THE GRAVES OF MY FAMILY
MEMBERS. LOCALS BOTH LOCALS AS
WELL AS LOCAL OFFICIALS TOLD ME
THAT. WHEN AZERBAIJAN
CONTROLLED THAT REGION DURING
THE SOVIET ERA. THEY DESTROYED
MANY ARMENIAN CEMETERIES AND
GRAVES. THE PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
DIE WILL NOT DIE. THAT'S THE
ONE THOUGHT I WANNA LEAVE WITH
ALL OF YOU FOLKS BECAUSE- THERE
WAS A MASS ATTEMPT TO MURDER AN
ENTIRE POPULATION. BUT WE STAND.
DR MARIJA TOOT ONCE SAID HOME
IS NOT WHERE MY GRANDPARENTS
ARE BURIED BUT WHERE MY GRAND
CHILDREN ARE RAISED. CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO THE THIRD LARGEST
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY IN THE
WORLD. THREE GENERATIONS OF MY
FAMILY HAVE LIVED IN FOUR
DIFFERENT PARTS. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST HUNDRED AND
TEN YEARS BEFORE FINALLY
SETTLING IN THE UNITED STATES.
THIS MOTIVATED ME TO RUN FOR
OFFICE. I WANT TO SHOW MY KIDS
THAT CALIFORNIA IS THEIR HOME
WE WILL NOT FLEE WE WILL NOT
RUN WE WILL NOT HIDE. WE WILL
NOT MOVE. WE ARE HERE TO STAY
AND I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT THE
FORTY SIXTH DISTRICT IN LOS
ANGELES AND IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. THANK. THANK EMISSIONS
AREA MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AND MEMBERS I'M
HONORED TO RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND CONSTITUENTS
BUT I SUPPORT. IN SUPPORT OF HR
TWENTY ONE. TODAY WE RECOGNIZE
THE HUNDRED AND SIX ANNIVERSARY.
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE A TRAGEDY
THAT HAS GONE UNRECOGNIZED BY
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY FOR
FAR TOO LONG. BUT NOW WE'RE AT
A TURNING POINT. THE
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH ON SATURDAY
SHOWS THE LEADERSHIP MANY OF
THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY I'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR FROM THEIR
ADOPTED COUNTRY. AS PRESIDENT
BY AND PUT IT IN A STATEMENT.
OVER THE DECADES ARMENIAN
AMERICANS AND ARMENIAN
IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN RESCUED
NINE STATES AND COUNTLESS WAYS
BUT THEY HAVE NEVER FORGOTTEN
THE TRAGIC HISTORY THAT BROUGHT
SO MANY OF THEIR ANCESTORS TO
OUR SHORES. WE ARE FIRM THEIR
HISTORY. FROM THE MIDDLE
PASSAGE TO JIM CROW THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IDENTIFIES
WITH THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY IN
THE PAYING. SUFFERING AND DEATH
INFLICTED UPON OUR PEOPLE FOR
NO OTHER REASON BUT HATE. WHICH
INDEED IS POISON TO THE SOUL.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER ON
THIS ISSUE FOR MANY YEARS AND I
THINK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM VAN
NUYS FOR BEING A TIRELESS
ADVOCATE AND REPRESENTATIVE FOR
HIS COMMUNITY. AS WE
COMMEMORATE THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE TRAGEDY WE MUST REMEMBER.
THAT IN A SENSE. THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE DID NOT IN. IT
CONTINUES TODAY. GENOCIDE
SCHOLAR GREGORY STAN PUTS IT
BEST WHEN HE SAYS THE NILE IS
THE LAST STAGE OF GENOCIDE.
TURKEY NOT ONLY DENIES THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE BUT CONTINUES
TO ENGAGE IN ONGOING WELL
FUNDED CAMPAIGN TO DENY THE
GENOCIDE AND BLAME THE VICTIMS
FOR WHAT HAPPENED. WITHOUT
FACING ANY ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
PAST ACTIONS TURKEY CONTINUES
TO FEEL ANTI ARMENIAN VIOLENCE
DOMESTICALLY AND IN AZERBAIJAN.
INCLUDING BANKROLLING TERRORIST
MERCENARIES FOR AZERBAIJAN'S
WAR AGAINST ARMENIAN CONTROLLED
NAGORNO KARABAKH REPUBLIC. FOR
MANY FAMILIES WHO LOST PARENTS.
GRANDPARENTS AND FRIENDS IN THE
GENOCIDE THE CURRENT CONFLICT
IS MORE THAN SALT IN THE WOUND
IT IS A NICE. THIS RESOLUTION
IS NOT JUST ABOUT REMEMBERING
THE PAST BUT IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT WHAT
WE CAN DO TO STOP THE
AGGRESSION AGAINST ARMENIANS
TODAY. EVEN IF IT'S JUST
RAISING OUR VOICE. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I
THINK ARE CALLINGAND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN
MS FRIEDMAN. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU MEMBERS. I AM
VERY PROUD TO REPRESENT A
DISTRICT THAT HAS THE LARGEST
CONCENTRATION OF ARMENIANS. I
BELIEVE IN THE UNITED STATES A
POSSIBLY OUTSIDE OF ARMENIA
ITSELF. AND I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS. TO RECOGNIZE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. AS JEWS WE
FEEL A VERY CLOSE KINSHIP WITH
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE FOR OBVIOUS
REASONS BOTH PEOPLE HAVE
SUFFERED WITHIN THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY GENOCIDES. BUT WHEREAS
THE JEWISH PEOPLE HAVE HAD THE
BENEFIT OF MOST OF THE
COUNTRIES OF THE WORLD
RECOGNIZING THAT THEHOLOCAUST
OCCURRED IT HAPPENED SO
RECENTLY THAT IT'S- DIFFICULT
TO DENY IT. ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
THOSE WHO WOULD TRY EVEN IN
THIS DAY AND AGE. THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE ON THE OTHER HAND HAS
BEEN DENIED. HAS BEEN
DISCOUNTED. UNTIL VERY
RECENTLY. INCLUDING HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES. JUST THIS
SATURDAY JOE BIDEN CALLED THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE FOR WHAT IT
IS A GENOCIDE THE FIRST MODERN
PRESIDENT. IN HISTORY TO DO SO.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THE AMOUNT OF
RELIEF. THAT MY ONSTITUENTS
HAD IN THAT MOMENT IT WAS LIKE
A COLLECTIVE SIGH. A GUN ACROSS
THE COMMUNITIES OF BURBANK AND
GLENDALE PEOPLE SAID FINALLY A
U. S. PRESIDENT IS ADMITTING
THAT WE INDEED SUFFERED
GENOCIDE. BUT I MUST ALSO TELL
YOU MEMBERS BUT THAT IS
TEMPERED BY THE INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF PAIN THAT THIS
COMMUNITY HAS SUFFERED IN THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF. WITH THE
ATTACKS ON ARTSAKH. IN ARMENIA.
THE AMOUNT OF DESPAIR OF
ANGUISH OF THREAT A VIOLATION
THAT THESE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
SO TRAUMATIZED THROUGH DIASPORA
THROUGH WAR THROUGH GENOCIDE
WITHIN RECENT REMEMBRANCE OF
RELATIVES AND THE FEELING. THAT-PERHAPS HISTORY WAS ABOUT TO
REPEAT ITSELF. HOW MY FRIEND
FROM VAN NUYS. THE CHAIR OF THE
ARMENIAN CAUCUS OF WHICH I AM
PROUD TO BE A MEMBER SPOKE SO
ELOQUENTLY AND SO POWERFULLY
ABOUT WHAT THIS MEANS. TO THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE. BUT I ASK YOU
ALL THAT AS WE RECOGNIZE THE
GENOCIDE TODAY AND WHEN WE SAY%
NEVER AGAIN TO ALSO REMEMBER
THAT THAT MEANS STANDING UP
TODAY. AGAINST WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN ARMENIA.
A PUSHING OUR ALLIES PUSHING
OUR OWN GOVERNMENT TO TAKE A
MORE ACTIVE STAND TO PREVENT
CONTINUED AGGRESSION CONTINUED
WAR CONTINUE MURDER OF THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE. NOW ARE
CALLING FROM VAN NUYS DID BRING
ME TO ARMENIA AND ARTSAKH A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. UNTIL YOU
WALK IN ARTSAKH AND FEEL AND
SEE FOR YOURSELF. THE LAYERS OF
GENERATIONS AFTER GENERATIONS
OF ARMENIAN HISTORY THAT IS
WOVEN INTO THAT COUNTRY THE
ENGINE ARMENIAN WORDS. THAT
GOING BACK AS FAR AS A FOR
CENTURY WERE CARVED INTO
CHURCHES AND MONASTERIES THE C.
THE GRAVEYARDS. ONLY THEN YOU
WILL UNDERSTAND THE INCREDIBLE
CONNECTION THAT THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE HAVE TO THAT REGION IT
IS OUR ANCESTRAL HOMELAND AND
JUST WITHIN THE LAST YEAR. TO
SEE INNOCENT ARMENIAN BLOOD
SPILLED ON ARMENIAN CROPS IN
ARMENIAN CHURCHES AND ARMENIAN
HOMES. ONLY THEN CAN YOU
REALIZE THE THREAT THAT IS
HAPPENING TO THIS VERY SMALL.
NATION TRYING TO REINVENT
ITSELF SO I ASK YOU TODAY IS WE
SAY NEVER AGAIN I RECOGNIZE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE TO ALSO
COMMIT TO TAKING A STAND. TO BE
LOUD AND TO BE DEMANDING THAT
WE DON'T ALLOW A GENOCIDE TO
HAPPEN AGAIN IN OUR MISS RIGHT
NOW OVERSEAS IN ARMENIA THANK
YOU MEMBERS. THANK GOODNESS
FRIEDMAN MR LACKEY WHO ARE
RECOGNIZED THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES. I STAND AS A PROUD
CO AUTHOR A MAJOR TWENTY ONE
AND DOESN'T ADOPTED MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDIAN
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. THIS
RESOLUTION. HONORS THE ONE AND
A HALF MILLION ARMENIANS THAT
WARM ACTUALLY MASSACRE. AT THE
HANDS OF THE TURKISH OTTOMAN.
EMPIRE THE TURKISH LEADERS ARE
CONTINUING AS YOU HEARD BY ALL
THE PREVIOUS COLLEAGUES TO DENY
THE GENOCIDE EVER EVEN TOOK
PLACE. AND THE REFUSE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ITS ACTIONS.
SADLY HUNDRED SIX YEARS LATER
THE SURVIVORS ARE NOW ALL GONE.
AND THEY NEVER LIVED TO SEE
THIS ATROCITY OF KNOWLEDGE. MY
DISTRICT DIRECTORS GREAT AUNT
WAS A VICTIM OF THE GENOCIDE.
AND I WANT TO BRIEFLY SHARE HER
STORY. AFTER HER HUSBAND WAS
MURDERED SHE WAS FORCED INTO
THE DESERT FOR THE DEATH MARCH.
DURING THAT TIME HER SIX MONTH
OLD BABY DIED IN HER ARMS. AND
SHE WAS LEFT FOR DEAD IN THE
DESERT. HOWEVER THANKFULLY SHE
WAS FOUND AND SHE WAS NURSED
BACK TO HEALTH AND HIDDEN. SHE
SERVED AS A MADE TO THE PEOPLE
WHO FOUNDER AND YEARS LATER
WERE ABLE TO REUNITE HER WITH
HER BROTHER IN THIS GREAT
AMERICA. SHE PASSED AWAY AT THE
AGE OF NINETY YEARS OLD. AS WAS
SAID BY PREVIOUS COLLEAGUES.
STATEMENTS OF THE NILE FROM THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT ALARMINGLY
CONTINUE. THIS RESOLUTION
ACKERLEY LABELS THE EVENTS OF
THE NINETEEN FIFTEEN.
APPROPRIATELY AS GENOCIDE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS WHERE THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
MITCHELL AKKI MYSTERON MAS YOUR
RECORD AS FROM YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE
AS THE NEWLY FORMED- CHAIRMAN
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY
ONE IN THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE WHO
SO LONG WERE DENIED THE FULL
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE GENOCIDE
IS SUFFERING THEY ENDURED.
GENOCIDE IS NOT A TERM TO BE
USED LIGHTLY. IT SPECIFICALLY
REFERS TO THE STATE SANCTION
ATTEMPT TO EXTERMINATE A GROUP
OF PEOPLE AND CAUSING SERIOUS
BODILY OR MENTAL HARM TO THE
MEMBERS OF THAT GROUP. AND
SEPARATION OF FAMILIES AND
PREVENTING BURGERS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS GONE ON IN
THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES. FOR MANY YEARS OF
THE ATROCITIES AND GENOCIDE
THAT FINALLY THE GOVERNOR SENT
OUT AN APOLOGY FOR THE TRUSTEES
AND GENOCIDE THAT TOOK PLACE
AGAINST THE NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE STAND WE
STAND WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KNOWS AREA WHO NOTED IN HIS
RULES COMMITTEE PRESENTATION.
THE JEWISH AND NATIVE AMERICAN
PAPPAS'S ARE ALTERED MILK TO
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT GENOCIDE
MEANS AND ITS AFTERMATH. THESE
ARE THE CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY
SUFFERED BY THE- ARMENIAN
PEOPLE WHICH BEGAN MORE THAN A
CENTURY AGO. ON SATURDAY THAT
HAS BEEN MENTIONED FOR THE
FIRST TIME FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HISTORY THE UNITED STATES
UNDER PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WRONGS IN THE
ATROCITIES AND GENOCIDE
INFLICTED UPON THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE OF OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ARMENIANS. IN ARMENIAN
STILL WAIT. ON APOLOGY OR EVEN
JUST ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THAT
ATROCITY FROM THE TURKISH
GOVERNMENT. I STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE ARMENIAN
PEOPLE. WHO HAVE SUFFERED.
CALLOUSLY AND I'VE HAD
EDUCATION IN THE EMISSIONS OF
THOSE ATROCITIES INFLICTED UPON
THEM. THAT HAVE NOT MOVE
FORWARD IN THE EYES NOT ONLY IN
THE UNITED STATES BUT IN THE
EYES OF THE WORLD. WE CAN ONLY
MOVE FORWARD WHEN THERE IS A
KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF A WRONG.
WITHOUT THAT ACKNOWLEDGMENT
ATTEMPTS TO RIGHT WRONGS CANNOT
TAKE ROOT AND BLOSSOM. WE STAND
IN SOLIDARITY AND URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THE RESTAURANTS MISS
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
NUMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
TWENTY ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO HONOR THE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION ARMENIANS WHO
PERISHED IN THE GENOCIDE THAT
BEGAN ON APRIL TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN FIFTEEN. THE
DESCENDANTS OF GENOCIDE
SURVIVORS CAME NOT ONLY TO THE
UNITED STATES AND CANADA BUT TO
LATIN AMERICA AS WELL BEGINNING
IN NINETEEN TWENTY THREE
ARMENIANS SETTLED IN MEXICO ON
THE WOULD I WHAT THE MY LAST
WEEK AT IOWA IS SOME OF THE
LORD AND CUBA. ARMENIANS IN
LATIN AMERICA WE'RE JOINED BY
EUROPEANS FLEEING FASCISM IN
THE NINETEEN THIRTIES AND
JEWISH SURVIVORS OF THE
HOLOCAUST IN NINETEEN FORTIES
AS SURVIVORS THEIR WISDOM
COURAGE AND EXAMPLE HELPED
SHAPE SOCIAL JUSTICE AND HUMAN
RIGHTS MOVEMENTS THAT BRIDGE
CULTURAL DIFFERENCES AND
TRANSCENDED BORDERS EVERY
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
FROM WOODROW WILSON TO THE
PRESENT. HAS BEEN CALLED UPON
TO OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE BUT NO
PRESIDENTE UNTIL JOE BIDEN DID
SO THIS YEAR FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY YEARS THE TRUTH CAPTURED
IN TESTIMONIES AND PRIMARY
SOURCE MATERIAL WENT UNSPOKEN
BUT GENERATION AFTER GENERATION
THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY REFUSE
TO LET THEIR VOICES BE
SILENCED. IT GIVES ME GREAT
PRIDE TO SAY THAT I HAVE
MARCHED ALONGSIDE MANY OF
ARMENIAN SISTERS AND BROTHERS
ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH WITH A
LARGE CONTINGENT THE CONTENTION
OF BLACK LATINO API NATIVE
AMERICAN AND WHITE CALIFORNIANS
SIDE BY SIDE IN SOLIDARITY.
THESE ARE THE VERY SAME
ARMENIAN SISTERS AND BROTHERS
WHO MARCHED SIDE BY SIDE WITH
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND
MAKE STATUS FAMILIES CALLING
FOR AN END TO MASS DETENTIONS
AND DEPORTATIONS ON MAY FIRST.
THOSE WERE THE VERY SAME
ARMENIAN SISTERS AND BROTHERS
WHO MARCHED SIDE BY SIDE WITH
CALIFORNIANS OF EVERY AGE
BACKGROUND TO RAISE THE MINIMUM
WAGE TO ENSURE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE FOR ALL PEOPLE AND TO
HONOR THE LEGACY OF MARTIN
LUTHER KING. IT WAS DR KING WHO
EXPLAINED THAT WE ARE CAUGHT IN
AN INESCAPABLE NETWORK OF
MUTUALITY. TIED IN A SINGLE
GARMENT OF DESTINY. AND THAT
WHATEVER AFFECTS ONE DIRECTLY
AFFECTS US. KAKA'S BELIEVE THAT
OURS IS A MORE GOLDEN STATE AND
THAT THE STARS OF THE AMERICAN
FLAG SHINE BRIGHTER. ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES ONLY CELEBRATE
OUR DIFFERENCES COME TOGETHER
INTERSECTIONAL AN INTER WOVEN
WAYS UNTIL OUR SOLIDARITY.
MAKES AS ONE INSEPARABLE
FABRIC. WITH US MANY THREADS
YARNS TEXTURES. AND COLORS AS
THERE ARE PEOPLE. IN HONOR OF
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM VAN NUYS WHO
IS THE FIRST IRANIAN BORN
ELECTED MEMBER TO THIS BODY AND
WHO HAS FIRMLY STOOD STRONG FOR
THE PAST EIGHT YEARS DOING THIS
RECOGNITION AND IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION. IN HONOR OF THOSE
WHO PERISHED IN HONOR OF THOSE
WHO SURVIVED AND MAKE THE TRUTH
KNOWN IN HONOR OF ALL THOSE WHO
MADE THIS DAY OF RECOGNITION
POSSIBLE AND IN HONOR. OF
HEALING DEEP WARMTH I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE RECOGNITION OF THE AMERICA
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND
URGE HER AYE VOTE ON HR TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU. MISTER GIBSON
IN THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF HOUSE RESOLUTIONS TWENTY
ONE. A BILL LIKE PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN TO DECLARE FORMALLY
RECOGNIZING THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE AND ESTABLISHING-
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH AS A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE. DURING THE ONE
HUNDREDTH COMMEMORATION OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE I STOOD WITH
SO MANY MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS
FROM DIFFERENT RACES CREEDS AND
COLORS IN SOLIDARITY. WITH YOUR
IMMEDIATE WITH ARMENIAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. WE STOOD
WITH THEM THEY STOOD WITH US
DURING BLACK LIVES MATTERS AS
THROUGHOUT THE CITY OF LOS
ALTOS IN OTHER PLACES. I AM
PROUD AS A MEMBER OF THE
ARMENIAN CAUCUS AS WELL AS
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. TO
STAND TODAY ON THIS ONE HUNDRED
AND SIX COMMEMORATION OF
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND SAY THAT
WE STAND WITH YOU WILL NEVER
FORGET. IN ADDITION TO THAT I
WANT TO THANK MY BROTHER NOW MY
COLLEAGUE MY BROTHER FROM- FROM
VAN NUYS FOR A CAN'T CONTINUE
TO MAKE THIS A YEARLY EVENT
WHERE- WE WILL NEVER FORGET ON
THIS ON THIS FLOOR IN THIS
HOUSE. HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR
US TO REFLECT BUT ALSO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY AND I THINK THE WAY
WE DO THAT IS MAKING SURE THAT
WE- ARE NOT FOUND GUILTY. BEING
SILENT. ON THE THINGS THAT
MATTER THAT'S WHAT DR MARK THE
KING SAID CERTAINLY. THAT
YOU'VE BEEN STANDING ON THIS
FLOOR. TIME AND TIME AGAIN
REMINDING US THAT THIS MATTERS.
AND I'M SO GRATEFUL. THAT OUR
PRESIDENT HAD THE COURAGE TO
STAND. AND STAND WITH KNOWLEDGE
OF MEANING ARMENIAN COMMUNITY
BUT STAND TO DO SOMETHING OTHER
PRESIDENTS HAVE NOT DONE. HAVE
NOT DONE. AND THIS PRESIDENT
STOOD LOUD AND CLEAR. AND IT
MAKES YOU FEEL A SENSE OF PRIDE
AS AN AMERICAN WE CAN STAND
WITH OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
AS AMERICANS AND SUPPORT THEM.
BUT NEVER BE FOUND GUILTY OF
BEING SILENT ON THE THINGS THAT
MATTER SO I ABSOLUTELY ASK FOR
STRONG AYE VOTE. HR TWENTY ONE
I THINK MY BROTHER PREVENT ICE
OF BRINGING IT YET ANOTHER TIME
ON OUR FLOOR IN OUR MEMBERS WE
SHOULD NEVER FORGET. THANK YOU
IS GIPSON MISTER CALDERON. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN PROUD SUPPORT OF HR
TWENTY ONE. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A VIBRANT
ARMENIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
THE LARGEST DIASPORA COMMUNITY
IN THE WORLD. THIS COMMUNITY
CONTINUES TO BE HEAVILY
AFFECTED BY AGGRESSION HATE AND
WAR CRIMES. IN OUR STATE THE
SAN FRANCISCO ARMENIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY WAS SUBJECTED TO HATE
CRIMES WHEN THE KZTV ARMENIAN
SCHOOL WAS VANDALIZED AND LATER
THE ST GREGORY THE ILLUMINATOR
ARMENIAN APOSTOLATE CHURCHES
CENTER WAS FACED WITH AN ARSON
ATTACK. INTERNATIONALLY THIS
COMMUNITY WAS IMPACTED BY THE
UNPROVOKED ATTACKS ON THE
REPUBLIC OF ARTS OCT BY
AZERBAIJAN. TURKEY ENCOURAGED
AND SUPPORTED THESE UNPROVOKED
ATTACKS AGAINST ARMENIAN PEOPLE
AND WE CANNOT EMBOLDEN THE
TURKISH GOVERNMENT TO COMMIT
FURTHER CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY.
WE MUST SEND A STRONG MESSAGE
THAT CALIFORNIA CONDEMNS THE
DENIAL OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
THE ONGOING AGGRESSION AT HOME
AND ABROAD AND HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AGAINST THE PEOPLE
OF ARTSAKH. CALIFORNIA HAS A
PROUD HISTORY AND STRONG RECORD
OF CONDEMNING JUSTICE AND HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN CONDEMNED
SOUTH AFRICA'S APARTHEID
APARTHEID POLICY AND FIND A
DIVERTISSEMENT BILL. GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER SIGNED A SEDAN
DEVELOPMENT THOUGH DUE TO THE
ONGOING GENOCIDE IN DARFUR. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT IS A STATE WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
CONDEMN VIOLATIONS OF HUMAN
RIGHTS AND THE DENIAL OF
GENOCIDE. THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU IS CALDERON IS VALID
THERE'S- YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY
ONE AND IS ALSO IS AN ADOPTED
MEMBER OF THE ARMENIAN CAUCUS
THIS YEAR MARKS THE ONE HUNDRED
AND SIX ANNIVERSARY OF THE
HORRIFIC GENOCIDE GENOCIDE OF
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION ARMENIAN
WOMEN CHILDREN AND MEN AT THE
HANDS OF THE OTTOMAN TURKS. AND
MY DISTRICTS SANTA CLARITA SIMI
VALLEY THERE'S ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND.
PEOPLE LIVING IN MY COMMUNITY.
I THINK OF MY NEIGHBOR I THINK
OF THE DONUT SHOP OWNER. BUT MY
FAMILY ACROSS TOWN OF THE
SCHOOL ACROSS THE STREET. AND
CAN ONLY IMAGINE MY COMMUNITY
BEING DECIMATED. TIMES THREE
THINK OF EACH OF YOUR DISTRICTS
YOUR FAMILIES YOUR FRIENDS THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU REPRESENT THAT
ARE YOUR VOICE TIMES THREE. MY
DISTRICT IS HOME TO THOUSANDS
OF ARMENIAN AMERICANS WHOSE
FAMILY IMMIGRATED TO THIS
COUNTRY. WITH NOTHING BUT THE
CLOTHES ON THEIR BACKS AND
THEIR LIVES. THIS COUNTRY OFFER
THEM SALAS HOPE. AND A NEW HOME
TO REBUILD THEIR LIVES. THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE SHOULD NO
LONGER BE IGNORED BY ANY
COUNTRY AND I AM PROUD THAT THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA HAS
RECOGNIZED THIS ATROCITY I
STAND WITH THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE
AND MY COMMUNITY IN RECOGNIZING
THEIR TRIUMPH OVER TYRANNY. THE
WILL TO FLOORS IN THIS COUNTRY-
THE RICH HISTORY AND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND OUR GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I STAND
WITH MY COLLEAGUES TODAY AND MY
COUNTRYMEN. AND RECOGNIZING THE
BEAUTIFUL BRUTAL ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE AND I STRONGLY URGE
FOR YOUR BY VOTE ON HR TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THEY GIVE US
VALDERS MS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. ALSO RISE
AS A PROUD ALLY MEMBER OF THE
ARMENIAN CAUCUS BUT IT'S WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT WE REMEMBER
THE LIVES LOST IN THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE ONE HUNDRED AND SIX
YEARS AGO. ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ARMENIANS WE KEEP
HEARING THIS NUMBER. ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION ARMENIANS LIVES
WERE LOST DURING THESE TRAGIC
TIMES. THE TIME AND HUMAN
RIGHTS WERE DISREGARDED. BUT
NEVER AGAIN. TODAY WE PAUSE WE
REFLECT REMEMBER AND WE SAY
AGAIN NEVER AGAIN. WE REMEMBER
THIS EVENT NOT ONLY TO HONOR
THE LIVES LOST BUT ALSO TO
ENSURE THAT CRIMES LIKE THESE
ARE NOT OVERLOOKED AND IN FACT
ARE STOPPED. I ALSO WANT TO
CELEBRATE THAT THE CULTURE HAS
SURVIVED IS PARTIALLY
REPRESENTED IN THE BOOK.
PRESENTED BY OUR COLLEAGUE
WHICH IS ON OUR DESK. I THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM VAN NUYS FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD TODAY. AND I STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH MY ARMENIAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN THIS
REMEMBRANCE. AND I ALSO THINK
OUR PRESIDENT. JOSEPH BIDEN FOR
BEING THE FIRST PRESIDENT TO
RECOGNIZE THIS EVENT FOR WHAT
IT IS FOR WHAT IT WAS THE
GENOCIDE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU MISS REYES SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEE A RECOGNITION ON
THE RESOLUTION. MISTER NAZARIAN
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FIRST
AND FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES- WHO HAVE
BEEN SUPPORTIVE OVER THE YEARS
BUT ESPECIALLY THE ONES WHO
SPOKE TODAY ON THE FLOOR FROM
PASADENA GLENDALE AND A LITTLE
BELLY. RANCHO CUCAMONGA. EAGLE
ROCK. WHITTIER VALENCIA MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CARSON OF WHO
ALSO REFERENCE THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR I USUALLY
REFERENCE OF MYSELF BECAUSE- HE
SO ELOQUENTLY CAPTURES THE
ESSENCE OF WHAT STRUGGLE IS.
AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAMBAR
DINO WHO ALSO POINTED OUT THE
PRESIDENT'S RECOGNITION AS WELL
AS THE BOOK THAT'S ON ALL OF
YOUR DESKS- IT'S WITH GREAT
HUMILITY ALSO THAT I EXTEND.
HUMBLE GRATITUDE ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF THE COMMUNITY AND ALL OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE PRESIDENT.
NOT JUST FOR RECOGNIZING THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE BUT RESTORING
FAITH. IN HUMANITY THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE ALONG WITH MANY OTHER
GENOCIDES ARE JUST THE SYMPTOM
OF WHAT WE DO TO ONE ANOTHER
AND SO. IT'S A IT'S A WIN FOR
ALL OF HUMANITY- AS FOR THE
BOOK THAT'S ON YOUR DESK LAVAGE
IS THE ARMENIAN WORK FOR FLAT
BREAD GIVEN THE ATTACK AND A
SENSELESS BRUTAL KILLINGS OF
ARMENIAN SOLDIERS AND CIVILIANS
AND THE TAKING OF- ANCESTRAL
LANDS LAST YEAR IT WAS
DIFFICULT TO JUST MERELY GIVE
ALL OF YOU A BOOK. BUT AS IS
THE COMMON PLACE FOR MANY
ANCIENT PEOPLES WHO HAVE
SURVIVED THE TORMENTS OF
CENTURIES AND MILLENNIA. IT'S
THE TABLE OF FOOD THAT'S THE
COMMONPLACE AND THE SIMPLE
DENOMINATOR THAT BRINGS ALL OF
US TOGETHER. TO BE ABLE TO
SHARE EXPERIENCES AND TO SHOW
REBIRTH. AND TO SHOW. CONTINUED
EXISTENCE. AND MORE THAN
SURVIVAL THRIVING. SO WITH THAT
HEY THANK ALL OF YOU AND HUMBLY
ASKED FOR THE FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPENED FOR COLLECTORS THANK YOU.
THANK EMISSIONS- AND WITH THAT
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS AT HR TWENTY ONE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL THEIR
SEVENTY FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY THREE. HR THIRTY EIGHT BY
MISS CARILLO CORKERY. HOUSE
RESOLUTION THIRTY EIGHT BY
SUMMER CARILLO RELATIVE TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT. MYSTERY OF.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
NUMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
HR THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
RECOGNIZES APRIL AS SEXUAL
ASSAULT AWARENESS MONTH AND
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH AS DENIM
DAY IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
THE ITALIAN SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNED THE CONVICTION OF A
MAN WHO SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD YOUNG WOMAN
BECAUSE SHE WAS WEARING QUOTE.
VERY TIGHT JEANS IN THE MIDST
OF IN THE MINDS OF THE OF THE
MALE JURIES THAT MEANT TO.
PERHAPS THE- THAT THE WOMAN
HELP REMOVED IN THE MINDS OF
THE MALE JURIST- THEIR DECISION
WAS BASED ON THE FACT THAT THEY
THOUGHT THAT THIS YOUNG WOMAN
REMOVED HER OWN JEANS.
EXTRADITING EXTENDING THIS
AGREE JUST LOGIC WHAT FOLLOWED
WAS NO LONGER RATE BUT INSTEAD
CONSENSUAL THE OUTRAGEOUS AND
OFFENSIVE NATURE OF THIS
VERDICT TRIGGERED AN
INTERNATIONAL CALL TO ACTION
AND SINCE THAT TIME WEARING
DENIM ON THIS DAY SERVES AS
BOTH. AN ACT OF PROTEST AND
ANNOUNCEMENT OF ALL THE ACTIONS
THAT SEEK TO SILENCE VICTIMS
AND A SYMBOL OF ALLYSHIP AND
SOLIDARITY. WITH SURVIVOR WITH
SURVIVORS PEOPLE FROM EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC AND BACKGROUND ARM
HEART ARE HARMED BY SEXUAL
VIOLENCE BUT IT IMPACTS WOMEN
AT A HIGHER RATE. ONE IN FIVE
MEN EXPERIENCE SOME SORT OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THEIR
LIFETIME BUT FOR WOMEN IT'S ONE
INTO. THE IMPACT OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT LAST LONGER THAN THE
HARMFUL ACT TAKES PLACE IN
ADDITION TO THE IMMEDIATE
PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL COST
SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVORS.
REGULARLY SUFFER FROM SEVERE
AND LONG LASTING CONSEQUENCES
THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
MAY ALSO GRAPPLE WITH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DEPRESSION HOMELESSNESS
AND EATING DISORDER ATTEMPTS AT
SELF HARM INCLUDING ATTEMPTS TO
TAKE ONE'S OWN LIFE. THIS IS
WHY THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION HAVE
IDENTIFIED SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
RAPE CULTURE THAT ENABLED
ENABLE IT AS PUBLIC HEALTH
PROBLEMS. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
NATIONAL LEADER SETTING THE
STANDARD FOR AFFIRMATIVE
CONSENT PROMOTING APPROACHES
WITHIN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS THAT DO
MORE. THAN SEND TO THE NEEDS OF
SURVIVORS AND PROVIDING COLLEGE
STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO EMPOWER THEMSELVES
TO INTERVENE TO PREVENT
ASSAULT. AS ACTIVE BYSTANDERS.
THE BAD NEWS IS OUR WORK FAR
FROM FINISHED CALIFORNIA HAD
FOUR TOP FOURTEEN THOUSAND.
EIGHT HUNDRED REPORTED RAPE
CASES IN TWENTY NINETEEN. AGAIN
THAT'S. FOURTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED REPORTED RAPE CASES IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. RAPE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT ARE ALSO UNDER
REPORTED CRIMES WHICH MEANS THE
NUMBER OF SURVIVORS IS ACTUALLY
MUCH HIGHER AND WE KNOW THAT
AMID THE PULPIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THOSE NUMBERS HAVE
ONLY INCREASED. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT SEXUAL ASSAULTS ARE
COMMITTED BY SOMEONE THE
SURVIVOR NEW NOT A STRANGER.
YET THE KNEE JERK RESPONSE
SURVIVORS HERE REMAIN TO BE THE
SAME QUESTIONS LIKE. WHAT WERE
YOU WEARING WERE YOU DRINKING
THE TO LEAVE THEM ON. THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO EXCUSE FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT WEARING JEANS OR
ANYTHING ELSE IS NEVER AN
INVITATION. TO RAPE NO MEANS
NO. INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
IS UNACCEPTABLE IT IS
EVERYONE'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
STOP ASSAULT AND THE RAPE
CULTURE THAT ENABLES IT WHAT WE
NEED IS A SOCIETAL SHIFT IN
CULTURE. IN WHICH BOYS AND MEN
OUR ALLIES WERE BOYS AND MEN
ARE TAUGHT THAT RAPE IS WRONG
AND THAT SEXUAL ASSAULT IS
WRONG. RATHER THAN THE ISSUE
WARNINGS TO GIRLS AND WOMEN AND
HOW THEY CAN AVOID BEING
ASSAULTED. WE NEED A CULTURE OF
WHICH NO ONE FEELS UNSAFE ON
THE JOB AT SCHOOL OR AT HOME.
ONE IN WHICH SURVIVORS
REGARDLESS OF INCOME RACE
CULTURE GENDER IDENTITY
DISABILITY LANGUAGE OR
IMMIGRATION STATUS FEEL
COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD AND
RECEIVING THE HEALTH CARE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
OTHER SUPPORT. THEY NEED ONCE
THEY DO. ONE IN WHICH
PERPETRATORS ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE WITHOUT ATTACKING
THE CHARACTER AND THE
REPUTATION OF THE SURVIVORS. I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES FOR WEARING DENIM
TODAY. WE ALL HAVE MOTHERS
SISTERS DAUGHTERS WHO WISH TO
PROTECT AND WE WERE DONE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ELEVATING THE
CONVERSATION AND BRINGING
AWARENESS. THAT NO ITEM OF
CLOTHING SIGNALS AN INVITATION
FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT. MEMBERS
TRADITIONALLY WE WOULD HAVE
ACTIONS ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS
BUT DUE TO COVER THIS
RESOLUTION IS OUR ONE AND ONLY
ACTION FOR THIS YEAR. YOU ARE
ALSO WELCOME TO WEAR JEANS ON
WEDNESDAY WITH HIS DENIM DAY I
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS VALOR
CALIFORNIA. AND THE PEACE OVER
VIOLENCE FOUNDATION FOR THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION AND
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR HR
THIRTY EIGHT TO RECOGNIZE APRIL
AS SEXUAL ASSAULT AWARENESS
MONTH AND TO RECOGNIZE
WEDNESDAY. APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH
AT THE END OF DAY I REQUEST BY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE ROLE
TO BE OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS AND
I FOUND. YOUR IBOOK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HISTORY MISTER COOPER
YOUR- THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'M PROUD THAT MY VOICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HR THIRTY
EIGHT. SEXUAL ASSAULT AWARENESS
MONTH THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
HIGHLIGHT EDUCATE OUR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HOW IT NEGATIVELY
AFFECTS EVERY PERSON IN OUR
COMMUNITY. NEED TO TAKE ACTION
TO STOP SEXUAL ASSAULT. SEXUAL
ASSAULT REPRESENTS A RANGE OF
BEHAVIORS IT CAN TAKE MANY
FORMS FROM UNWANTED SEXUAL
CONTACT. SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
AND TRAFFICKING. APPROXIMATELY
ONE OF FOUR GIRLS AND ONE IN
SIX BOYS ARE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
BEFORE THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN.
BRING SEXUAL VIOLENCE FROM
HAPPENING IS A COMMUNITY WIDE
RESPONSIBILITY. HAS
CALIFORNIANS IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO RAISE
AWARENESS AROUND SEXUAL ASSAULT
HARASSMENT AND VIOLENCE IN
TAKES STEPS TO STOP THE ABUSE
BEFORE IT HAPPENS. I URGE RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ADAM. MIS CORREOS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLL BE OVER FOR
CO AUTHORS THAT YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH MISS KOREA. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR COOPER SINGER
I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS KOREA CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE
THERE ARE SEVENTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY DAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT.
THIS IS AC ARE SIXTY FOUR AND
IT REQUIRES A ROLL CALL VOTE
IT'S BEEN KEY FISCAL THIS IS A
RESOLUTION THAT WE HEARD ON
THIS FLOOR TODAY IT IS FISCAL
THEREFORE WE NEED A ROLL CALL
VOTE THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT AC ARE SIXTY FOUR. BY MR
FONG THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THAT ABOUT.
THIS IS A C. R. SIXTY FOR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS BETTER IS
THAT ABOUT ACR.
SIXTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS BETTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK. WELL CLOSER ALL.
CHINA VOTE I SEVENTY THREE NOES
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY THREE OF US ON
OUR WORK RELATIVE TO PURPLE
STAR SCHOOLS. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CITY
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT. THE
CLERK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SEVENTY SEVEN. NO ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT A GERMAN ST
MEMORY. WE ALSO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL MOTION THAT WE NEED
TO TAKE UP. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. MEMBERS WHILE
WE WAIT FOR THE PROCEDURAL VOTE
I'M GOING TO MOVE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND THEN WE WILL
MOVE TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
IF YOU SEE CHAD MAYES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES I WAS TAKING A
PICTURE RIGHT NOW MR MAYES- IS
CELEBRATED A BIRTHDAY ON
FRIDAY. HAPPY BIRTHDAY MR NAMES.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING UPON A GERMAN PART
ME THIRTY MINUTES AFTER GERMAN
THIRTY MINUTES AFTER GERMAN IN
THE CHAMBER THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR THIRTY
MINUTES. AFTER GERMAN. WHICH
WILL HAPPEN IMMINENTLY. CLOSEST
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
APRIL TWENTY CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY NINTH THE
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM. MS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA THE
FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE. TO MEET IN
ROOM FOUR TWO OH TWO AT FOUR
THIRTY PM TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR MEMBERS WE'RE TO
GERMANS. PLEASE CLEAR THE
AISLES PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MISTER COOPER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO DURING TODAY'S
SESSION IN THE MEMORY OF A
BELOVED COMMUNITY LEADER
ACTIVIST MOTHER GRANDMOTHER
GREAT GRANDMOTHER AND FRIEND
IRENE B. WEST. MRS WEST WAS
BORN IN CROWLEY LOUISIANA ON
JULY THIRD NINETEEN THIRTY TWO.
SHE TO FIFTEEN OVERSEE IN
TENNESSEE AND LATER GRADUATED
FROM SACRAMENTO STATE AFTER
MOVING TO THE AREA IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN SIXTIES OR HUSBAND WAS
STATIONED EVOQUA AIRFORCE BASE.
MRS WEST COMES MY FAMILY OF
TEACHERS AND WAS HIRED AS THE
FIRST BLACK TEACHER IN ELK
GROVE IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. AT
THE TIME L. GROW VIRTUALLY HAD
NO BLACK POPULATION HOWEVER
THIS DID NOT DETER HER FROM
EMBARKING ON A TRAILBLAZING
CAREER IN EDUCATION. MRS WEST
POINT TWENTY SEVEN YEARS IN THE
ABOVE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHERE SHE TAUGHT L. GROVE JAMES
MCKEE INFORM ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
AND SERVED AS PRINCIPAL OF JOHN
REEF THE CONSUMERS RIVER
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS. MRS WEST
RETIRED AS A PRINCIPAL OF
FRANKLIN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE BUT REMAIN
VERY ACTIVE IN AROUND HER
COMMUNITY WELL INTO HER
EIGHTIES IN TWO THOUSAND TWO I
READ THE WEST ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WAS NAMED IN HER HONOR FOR THE
TREMENDOUS LEGACY SHE LEFT.
SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE AN
INSPIRATION FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME HER TIRELESS WORK HAS
BROKEN MANY BARRIERS AND PAVE
THE WAY FOR OTHER AFRICAN
AMERICAN TEACHERS. HER DEATH IS
A HUGE LOSS FOR OUR COMMUNITY
AND WE KNOW THAT HER IMPACT ON
THE COMMUNITY IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN. MRS
WEST IS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY
HER LATE HUSBAND CLIFTON WEST
JUNIOR MR BLOOD BY HER FOUR
CHILDREN CLICK TO WEST THE
THIRD CORNEL WEST FIFTY
MCDANIEL WEST INTRAWEST SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN ELEVEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND THREE GREAT
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. MADRE
GRANDDAUGHTERS PHYLLIS COOK AS
WELL AS HER FORMER SON IN LAW
DAVID BOWMAN- MEMBERS OF OUR
CAPITAL FAMILY. MRS WEST
REMEMBERED AS A CONSUL BUT
ALWAYS WHEN OUT. OF HER WAY FOR
OTHERS SHOULD ALSO BE MA'AM AS
A WOMAN OF STRONG FAITH.
GRACIOUSNESS AND DEDICATION TO
THE LOWER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
TO RETURN MRS IRENE B. WEST
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISS COOPER
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WITH
HAS TO RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN IS FRIEDMAN MOVES AND
MISTER FLORA SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY NINTH AT
NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALL. IS
LIFTED.